so super happy to have you here man
really excited to talk to you it's been
a long time coming I think maybe we
first had emails I think in like 2009 or
something like that and we haven't met
until today it was back a while yeah I
know you reached out to me to you ask me
a few questions when you were working on
for our body which I didn't make the
book but that's okay no but I was stoked
to even to even talk to you and I think
before we even get into it I wanted to
thank you first of all for writing your
first book this book for our work week I
have the original one here which was
super helpful and instrumental in
helping me as I began this transition
out of law and into what I get to do
today and I think on a very kind of
practical tactical level figuring out
how I was going to train for these crazy
races and still make an income and it
was great like it really helped me a lot
and and so I appreciate you very much
for writing that book and then
secondarily I wanted to thank you
publicly for providing me the
opportunity to do a guest blog when
finding ultra came out which was really
like that helped me out a lot and so I
really appreciate thank you still gets a
lot of traffic yeah there's a little
like there was a little controversial
aspect about those
oh no I appreciated anything called the
superfood will will polarize ya know for
sure so I think the thing that I kind of
wanted to really get into into it with
you is this journey that you're kind of
on currently because when I think about
you I think about you know somebody who
has who has lived by this kind of rule
of coming up with not just tools but
kind of a roadmap for how you live like
you're somebody who in jonathan field
said this the other day i've listened to
that podcast like you're somebody who
I've always looked at as a person who
lives very much in their head who is
very intellectual in their approach to
life and it's reflected in the work that
you do this idea that you're dissecting
and and deconstructing you know how
other people do things and applying what
works for you into your own life but I
think like traditionally when I looked
at your work I've sort of missed the
more emotional heartfelt approach to
certain aspects of how how to live and
what I'm seeing in you now is a is like
a journey towards that like an embrace
of that in a certain way that I haven't
seen in you in the past and I celebrate
that I think that's really cool and
that's something I'd like to hear a
little bit more about let's get into it
thanks for having me first of all it's
really nice to be here and I think we're
all on different journeys their shared
traits perhaps for many of us and we hit
different legs in different portions of
our lives so for some people they start
off say in the heart or in the gut and
then move to the head later because they
need to learn to manage finances or
whatever might not suit me okay yeah and
then you have other people certainly I
would count myself among those people
who for whatever reason or combination
of reasons
develop a lot of armor really early on
as I did in childhood at some reasonably
uh bad things happen to me as a kid that
I don't really want to get into
specifics over but that encapsulates a
lot for a lot of people and put on this
incredible armor to protect myself and
only realized in the last few years that
and when you put on really effective
armor you do keep things out but you
also keep a lot in hmm and there were
certain ways that I had handicapped
myself very deliberately viewing a
motion as a weakness viewing attachment
emotional attachment in particular as a
weakness my priority for a very long
time was to simply hone myself as a as
an instrument of competition basically
and to use that to validate myself to
prove my worth and anything that
detracted from that or remotely made me
vulnerable I viewed as something that
should be disposed of so that led me to
the pro and con lists to the hyper
analytical to the as close as I could
manage spock-like approach with a high
pain tolerance to tackling different
things in life and that is just another
way of accepting partial completeness
which ironically I wrote about in the
4-hour body which is arguably the most
like I say clinical that makes it sound
really dry it's a I think it's a fun
book but it's very analytical right and
very quantified and I talk about how
people should question certain
assumptions they've made about what they
can or cannot do such as well my my
parents are fat I'm fat that's just the
way it is and they accept that as a
partial completeness and they never
challenge that but I myself never even
thought of my long-standing
lack of interest in emotion as a gap
does that make sense Oh probably as a
strength like I you know from what I've
heard in in how you talk about your
childhood there's a lot of similarities
with my childhood I was somebody who was
a very awkward kid I'm very much a loner
you know not a not by any stretch of the
imagination anybody who looked like they
were going to be an athlete you know
eyepatch headgear last get picked for
kickball and and really had a lot of
difficulty connecting with friends and
classmates and as a result spent a lot
of time alone then I discovered swimming
and I and I feel like I'm interested in
talking to you a little bit about this I
feel like the relationship that I
developed with that sport is similar to
the relationship that you developed with
wrestling at that time because I
approached it as it was the first thing
I was actually good at you know and it
was kind of this safe place away from
school and I realized very early and
often that the more I put into it the
better I got so that equation of being
diligent and being devoted and working
hard had very practical real-world
results that were advancing my life in a
very good way but it was also a place
where I could go and not have to deal it
was certain it was like us not only a
safe place but a place away where I
could just escape so in some respects I
think I had a compulsive obsessive
addictive relationship with it and it
was a means of not having to deal with
some emotional stuff that I was going
through but when you become successful
when it's moving you forward it's much
more of a reason to continue to not look
at that other aspect of your life
because it's serving you the others
there's a huge amount of overlap so
wrestling for me as a as someone born
premature I was very very small until
sixth grade I mean just gotten
constantly on a daily basis
I was so small it was such a small kid I
would I would generally not even opt to
go out to recess because that was just
like going out into the terrible the the
open sky pen at like a federal prison I
mean that was a dangerous place for me
to be out just get dragged around and
punched and so on so I'd read books and
that was the the cover that I used to
sit on the step right outside of the
door that went out to recess and
wrestling which came to me really by
luck because I was hyperactive and my
mom was told by other moms that kid
wrestling would be a good way to drain
my batteries put into wrestling and then
I think both of us realized that it was
the one sport since it was weight class
based that I had access to where I could
end up being matched against another
equally puny nerdy kid and at least one
of us got to win yeah but to underscore
something you said which i think is very
true for me as well as that particularly
at that age but for a long time in
school at least you have fairly siloed
areas of life meaning you have academics
and it's easy to measure you do well at
you do poorly and then you have certain
sports particularly if it's an
individual sport where you feel like you
have some this is another reason I
gravitated towards wrestling a semblance
of control there's so many things you
can't control
but part of the reason I always ended up
leaning towards individual sports even
though I did play soccer for a short
period of time I played football for one
season which I did not like for a host
of reasons and wrestling on the other
hand the aula credit or all the blame
was on you lies on you yeah I mean
swimming even more so yes it's the
ultimate and self determinate ism yes
determinism right it's just you against
the clock I mean you're racing against
somebody else I mean a wrestling you
have your opponent you have to
anticipate what yeah
is gonna do and so that's a variable
that you let you don't have in a sport
like track and field or swimming but
right but it's very much that idea of
like you get out what you put into it
and there's that equation right and you
can like immerse yourself in that and
that becomes an identity no and I liked
the controlling of variables to the
extent possible and as you get older at
least just projecting forward if we fast
forward the film and get into 20s 30s
certainly 40s an hour more and more of
my friends have passed away right and
the decisions you make in your personal
life absolutely bleed over and affect
other parts of your life and the
decisions you make in one area that used
to be at least conceptually as a kid
really walled off and siloed bleed over
into every other and I think that many
of our strengths in xsb become or create
glaring weaknesses yeah for sure
so for me it was this realization and we
could really dig into some of the tools
that led to this realization including
supervised use of psychedelics that led
me to the conclusion that Mike my
current state of being was not only
unsustainable in a lot of ways but
really not serving me and that if I
wanted to not just tolerate myself which
I think at best is what I did for most
of my life then I had to rewire quite a
bit and it involved going back and
contending with some really old things
and that many of the seemingly disparate
behavioral challenges or short tempered
miss or impatience with myself or
berating myself in my own head or fill
in the blank it could be 20 or 30 things
that I tended to view as inexplicable
separate behaviors were in fact all
easily
back to a handful of things that I
protect I I think by necessity protected
myself against or felt the need to
protect myself against early on by
walling off myself emotionally mm-hmm
yeah these strengths can be can manifest
as as character weaknesses over time you
know and and I've had a similar journey
what's interesting about your your
journey is that you've you've lost
certain people in your life and that's
put you in a place of self-reflection
that has opened you up to entertain new
ideas and explore these areas that
you're exploring right now but you
didn't have to have some kind of
cataclysmic event in your own personal
life like usually people reach that
point of self-reflection when something
has gone really bad and you know like
they they lose everything or or what
have you and you know in my case it's
been a journey from self well to
surrender a place of understanding that
that self will is what is going to allow
me to make my way into the world like I
think I've heard you say like you have a
high pain threshold a high pain
tolerance like I certainly do right and
I've always considered that to be my
armor to be my strength I know that I'm
not the most talented person but I can
insert myself into a situation and I
know how to outwork the next guy and I
can bridge that talent deficit gap and
inch my way up close to you know where I
want to be by virtue of that
characteristic and I always consider
that to be almost like a superpower
right and it wasn't until I was
struggling with drugs and alcohol and
that brought me to my knees that I had
to find a different way because that
self-will I couldn't understand why that
self well wouldn't solve this problem
that in order to solve this problem I
had to let go of all of that and see it
through a completely different lens that
lens of surrender of completely letting
go and allowing other people in getting
to a place of being willing to ask for
help and then receive help because like
yourself you know I didn't like myself I
loathed myself for a very long period of
time and and got to a place of perhaps
tolerating myself but never knew what it
meant to
experience self-love and I'm still on
that journey but I had to go to an
incredibly dark place in order to access
that and you know it's a journey that
I've done since I've been 31 I'm 51 now
I still do it incredibly imperfectly but
it's brought it's brought ideas and a
sense of understanding into my life that
I never thought would be anything I
would be interested in that I would have
repelled as a younger person you know a
lot of woohoo stuff and stuff like hey
you know what I mean that I know you
have like an aversion to yeah but I see
you tiptoeing around the edge of this
and I think that that is very exciting
for you and and I think that if you
continue to pull on that thread the self
discovery and the personal growth that
you're gonna experience is gonna blow
your mind
I hope so I feel like it's already
coming I mean I feel like a few things
that some people listening might
identify with
well first may I drink this pds please
elixir so we have party here from our
friend Colin who Don of living tea so
again take it dramatic yeah priest story
sip of purity is good right all right so
a few things that people may resonate
with in might you might also identify
with because we do have a lot of sure
DNA have overlap all right so the pain
tolerance I think that embracing a high
pain tolerance or developing it was also
a coping mechanism that I use to silence
my inner voice because I was it was so
merciless and such a demon on my back
that at any given time if I scored just
even metaphorically speaking ninety-nine
out of a hundred the only thing that
mattered was the one thing that went
wrong
how could I be so stupid or so lazy or
so inept or so blind get that one thing
wrong and the immersion in physical pain
through wrestling through the training
that goes into it through the cutting of
weight which is just atrocious I think
was a coping mechanism that I used to
silence that and as as you've
experienced in your life high tolerance
is not always a good thing and it's I
ended up being introduced to really
strong stimulants in high school
ephedrine hydrochloride combined with
caffeine and aspirin and the whole nine
yards things beyond that and there were
tools that I also realized I could take
in in tremendous quantities compared to
other people which I which I viewed as a
superpower
maybe now you know there are superpowers
the different kind of pain tolerance
yeah and so the what I thought was a
gift ended up becoming a major handicap
and ultimately addiction for me that
really has only been kicked at least for
the time being in the last few years
I mean relying on stimulants of
different types and the the realization
that I had this partial completeness and
a lot of blind spots and also unresolved
facets of myself did come from some
really really tough periods and there
were there were many of them but one in
particular was several years ago at the
end the very end of a four and a half
year relationship and she was I mean
she's a beautiful human being we're
still friends to this day but she was as
opposite on the emotional spectrum or on
the empathic self compassion side of the
spectrum I compared to me as you is you
could possibly imagine I mean she felt
everything that everyone was feel
including herself all the time I mean
she was just one of those super empaths
which is actually sometimes crippling
for people and it's hard for them to
walk down the street and say New York
City because they just they seem to
genuinely feel everything that's right
on there so host like a full-body
synesthesia that's right yeah right my
wife calls it the Divine Feminine right
so this this woman experienced that and
it was such an odd combination that
worked for us meaning our very distinct
opposite size as a coin for a long time
until it didn't and I didn't have the
vocabulary or even like conceptual
schema to understand why she did certain
things the way she did it and it was
because I just I didn't have the ABCs of
emotion in myself mm-hmm and because it
was so locked down yeah so walked down
it was so locked down that I didn't
realize it was even a thing and it
didn't if that makes any sense
well I think you know it it just seemed
irrelevant and unpredictable and right
like this is not productive yes it's not
moving me forward and and my way works
because look at all these books that
I've written and look what I'm doing out
in the world and I with my you know
character makeup I got into Princeton
and I did that so there's no reason to
be self-reflective about it because
you're succeeding in the eyes of culture
and society right right but I would say
almost never in the in my own eyes
mm-hmm there was always I could have
there was always something I could have
done better there was always something I
screwed up and it was a it was a fear of
losing that kept me moving more than any
joy of winning mhm and never being able
to just like experience joy and
gratitude for the things that you have
been able to accomplish that has been
that has been a practice that I've
worked on in the last few years in
particular is there a fear of losing it
that accompanies that but it's all gonna
go away or just not being able to be
happy with it
well we could we could answer that as
Tim of say two years ago or Tim of today
it's not a Tim of two years ago Tim of
two years ago Tim of five years ago
especially felt a tremendous amount of
obligation to a lot of people and to
support a lot of people and to prepare
to support even more people and I felt
like I had to build a war chest just for
that so it's not a love of money it was
not a love of achievement a lot of it
was a fear of letting other people down
or it's a lot of pressure yeah causing
pain of some type for people I love and
I'm past that at this point me very
fortunately I've had a good string of
luck and successes so it's put me in a
position where I can support other
people but the the fact of the matter is
I realized I'd say two years ago but
especially in the last six months very
recent that and this is the part that
would make my Tim of five years ago just
Crane like vomit a little in his own
mouth but Jesus I'm not gonna mince
words I still have trouble sayings like
self love is not an indulgence it's not
a nice to have it is a prerequisite even
if all you want to do is feel successful
and take care of the people you love the
most to really take care of them you
have to as I've heard said put on your
oxygen mask first and if you don't do
that like you you are also shortchanging
your ability to care for other people
completely and that that's been a very
[Music]
very much an hundred and eighty degree
about-face for me right because for a
long time I was like I don't need to
care for myself I
that's the word keeps coming back to me
which is self-indulgent like this is
self-indulgent like who cares ultimately
it's really self flagellation
right because you can't you can't
transmit something you haven't got
so in other words you can't love another
unless you love yourself and you can't
be the best teacher or servant or human
being
you can't convey the best version of
yourself if you don't carry that
resonance for your own being and you
know one thing I didn't actually think
this until right now but nothing another
big change in my life in the last two
years has been getting my dog getting
Molly my first dog is an adult I've
always felt like half of a human being
without a dog I just have a very keen
connection with canines and I got Molly
two years ago two and a half years ago
and she's such a loving dog such a fast
learner and such a good mirror I mean I
began to see my flaws in the way I'd
never seen them before because I would
get impatient or upset if I was training
her for something and five minutes later
when I would reflect on it when I did I
what the hell is wrong with me like what
am I getting so wound up about this is a
dog has no malice doesn't is is nothing
but eager to please what are you so
wound up about and it in it I think his
has taught me in some ways how to love
period which has helped me to relate to
myself in a gentler way so that's also
been an incredible gift when you had
this realization was there a certain
person that you reached out to initially
or how did you begin the you know in the
Tim Ferriss way of cut you know trying
to unpack this aspect of yeah who you
are and how to move forward like who are
the people that you you dialed up I
there were a few things number one is I
try to observe changes and friends of
mine who are similarly hardwired and
there are a lot of people out there
taipei driven people or really brutal
with themselves mhm and very good at
achievement very poor at appreciation
particularly when it comes to anything
they've done and a friend of mine PhD in
neuroscience really tough on herself
recommended a book called radical
acceptance by Tara brach and just the
title alone I was like oh god I think I
so the amazing book downloaded it on
Kindle right away and promptly ignored
it for a few months and then eventually
I was in the pit of despair at some
point and the heaviest e2 suffered from
bipolar disorder for decades now which
has is no big surprise when you look at
my code from having sequenced my full
genome they're like oh yeah this thing
here like 20 out of from one to ten year
twenty but at one dark point picked up
that book actually not that far from
where we're sitting right now when I was
in Malibu at a friend's place and read
20 but 20 or 30 pages the first night
and just remember thinking to myself wow
like this is exactly the medicine that I
need and for those who don't have any
contacts to make thar is amazing she has
a very tough she's traveled a hard road
she's had some really difficult
experiences in her life and after
digging into that book I then had the
pretext of the podcast to use to reach
out to Tyra and say would you like to
put the podcast and all of my
conversations on my podcaster are pretty
selfishly or at least self-interested in
the sense that I'll use it as an excuse
to get someone liked are on the phone
for two hours and then just do a therapy
session of course it's the greatest
don't think I'm not gonna do that with
you before we're finished here go ahead
and I began to explore tiptoe
the walls of this this sort of new
structure are to tiptoe along the
boundary of this new world that I hadn't
explored and that extent to Sharon
Salzberg and reaching out then via other
friends to say jack Kornfield who has
not been on the podcast although I would
like to have him on at some point and
also looking to how my listeners
responded like did it resonate did it
repel not that that would determine
whether I proceeded or not but it was
reassuring to me and very reinforcing to
see how many people seem to need this
including folks at the top top top top
top of the game I mean whatever game
that might be you name it investing tech
sports culinary world you had you know
on some level you had a little bit of a
fear like oh you know my crew is not
he's gonna they're gonna they're gonna
get weirded out by the fact that I have
someone like Sharon on I wasn't it
wasn't so much a fear it was a
hypothesis it wasn't a hypothesis it was
more of an I wonder what will happen
when I put this out mhm
and I expected maybe the hey we want
more interviews with billionaire set
would would come back with a come on man
like this is okay but you can do better
and this is not what I come here for
and not wasn't the right that wasn't the
response that wasn't the response I
expected the woohoo folks to opt in
because that's what woohoo folks do with
woowoo stuff for things that they
perceived to be friendly and what ended
up happening was yes the woowoo folks
are very publicly supportive and then
all of these secretly pained people who
felt like they were uniquely damaged
reached out to me and said [ __ ] men like
I had no idea that you went through all
this stuff and like I've dealt with so
much of this and I I feel like I can't
talk to anyone about it and thank you
and that has been something that's
prodded me to continue to explore at
least public
privately I was gonna do it no matter
what but that has been a real driver for
me and wanting to be much more public
about all of this it's also the reason
why this was not an easy decision after
being invited to speak on the Ted main
stage the first time this past year as
context when you do a TED talk the way
it usually works as I as I know now is
you have people who labor over their
talk for months and months and months
and months they rehearse at thousands of
times and it's finally it finely honed
and ready to go when they step on stage
I did that and then a week about a week
before Ted right before the last final
rehearsal which is done via
videoconference with Ted and Krys
Anderson and and the other people at the
top at Ted I scrapped the entire talk
and pulled an all-nighter and put
together a new one because I had this
very safe very solid talk that I felt
would do well what was the subject of
the original talk the virginal talk was
the stuff that is my default go to just
competitive analysis and more Tim living
in his head more Tim living in his head
or just using prefrontal cortex to
figure out workarounds and non-obvious
solutions to different types of
competitive problems perfect audience
for that at Ted
fantastic and then I found out that the
talk would be in the opening session and
it would be broadcast to movie theaters
so hundreds or thousands of movie
theaters and I had this real unexpected
not gonna call it a panic attack but
like an existential I coming to Jesus
moment this in the afternoon before the
day before this rehearsal where I just
thought to myself what the [ __ ] are you
doing like you have a moral obligation
if you're gonna have that platform to
use it for something and you're gonna
get up and talk about like some
incremental human guinea pig [ __ ] and I
that is
I end up scrapping it and then doing the
entire talk on my clothes brush with
suicide in college and the safety nets
and approaches that had created to avoid
self-destruction because I felt like I
had to I just felt like something I had
to do and do you think that you just
you're describing it as a moral
obligation which sort of contextualizes
it as as a response to some external
pressure but it feels to me like it was
more like an internal dissonance like
this is not this is not authentic to
where I'm at right now and the message
that that I really want to express know
that that's exactly at night when when I
say moral obligation I don't view it as
externally imposed at all I feel and I
can and I have felt this way for a long
time that the with great audience comes
great responsibility and what are you
gonna do with it and I know people who
really abuse it or are really reckless
with it and give out advice that can
kill people regularly and don't add any
caveats or qualifiers which i think is
hugely responsible and I just felt like
this was a sideshow they psycho is the
same Japanese like first and last so
this is probably the only chance I'm
gonna get because why would they give it
to me twice to get on the main stage and
do this so yeah if we're gonna do it all
right yeah it's it's it's vulnerability
writ large like as large as it could
possibly be written right and yeah a
sense of being completely exposed
yeah and for people who weren't at Ted
which is the majority of people it's a
very intimidating crowd so there's also
part of me that felt to get on stage and
tell people like Jeff Bezos my recipe
for success was kind of preposterous I
was like okay well if I can't out
success then like let me not out fail
them but completely zigged instead of
zagged and the what astonished me was a
number of things
first right after the rehearsal on-site
which I was devastated they didn't
record because I completely nailed the
rehearsal and I was like do sometimes
just use the rehearsal they're like no
we didn't even record that I was like
because it the lighting the cameras
everything ready yeah
the Ray Dalio who's the founder of the
largest hedge fund in the world hundred
sixty billion dollars under management
Bridgewater associates came up to me and
wanted to thank me for the rehearsal
because his son had struggled for so
long with bipolar disorder and had
learned a lot and we talked for about
10-15 minutes the next day when I got up
and I gave the talk it's very very
nervous gave the talk and got off stage
and didn't really want to talk to
anybody because in that room and given
the lights it just felt too quiet it
mean when you were delivering when I was
delivering it was very hard for me to
read yeah yeah how people were
responding because unless you're and
unless you're telling jokes yeah you
don't you can't go even if you even if
you're telling jokes that coup sticks
and so on in the room or such that it's
very hard to tell what's going on and so
I got off stage and I really just wanted
to be by myself and just let out a long
exhale and decompress because I had done
it and even if it failed in the room
which I felt like it had I hoped that it
would do a lot of good once it went up
did you have a sense of catharsis though
I did I did so I did have a huge sense
of catharsis but I didn't really want to
go out and see anyone because I thought
that had flopped in the room nonetheless
I was really happy that I did it so the
way I was thinking of it was and I ended
up not killing myself
due to coincidence I mean we could get
into it if you want but I mean that the
the fact that I'm here today is a it's a
miracle because it wasn't it's not like
I talked my way or thought my way out of
not pulling the trigger it was just dumb
luck and a bunch of respects and I felt
like if that talked once it got released
acted as an intervention for even one
person great yeah I'm happy to be
embarrassed in front of a hundred and
you know Oh fifteen hundred movers and
shakers doesn't matter to me but what
ended up happening is I did a book
signing the next day in the same
building and hundreds of people came up
to tell me about in this audience keep
in mind anybody listening is like this
the audience at Ted it's just the who's
who it's a nutty intimidating crowd and
hundreds of them came up to confess
about having had close brushes of
suicide or to having chronic depression
or to having children who had committed
suicide or had been handicapped and felt
entirely alone because of similar
feelings and I would say at least a
third of the people there at some point
excite I came up the first day first
session first days and I was there for
the rest of the week I'd say probably a
third of the people there came up to me
with some personal story yeah well I
think that that uh that decision to be
vulnerable in that way is like a huge
move towards becoming a fully integrated
human being and I think that you know
speaking from my own personal experience
as somebody who's enjoyed your content
for a long time I feel like I and
probably a lot of other people we're
just waiting for you to tell us who you
are you know because I think for a long
time it's like I'm getting a lot of
great information from Tim for a script
like I know this stuff is like but who
is this guy like I don't even know that
I really know who this guy is like and I
know that I personally I was like I want
to know more about you you know and I
felt like that armor was was up so hard
that you didn't you weren't ready for
that or you even feel comfortable or
that or maybe you just thought well
that's not part of what works for me or
that's not how I want to live
you know publicly yeah but when you made
that decision it's not surprising I mean
first of all it's very courageous to
like get up and do that and then to have
that experience of being embraced it was
like I think everybody else like your
your fans people that follow you there
was a collective exhale like now we can
really embrace this guy because we have
a better understanding of who he is and
that's that's a really powerful thing
yeah I don't I don't think I was even
aware
I don't think I was aware of holding
anything back or consciously holding
anything back I just I didn't even yeah
I'm not surprised to see it didn't feel
conscious on your part they just felt
like but it was still like that's how I
was reading it Lee sure sure and that's
been a trip so I'm not convinced I fully
know myself yet certainly working you're
not enlightened yet yeah certainly
work-in-progress always but I'm enjoying
embracing a more extended palette of
colors mm-hmm and I've also come to
realize that historically if I've this
is gonna be met up but I've thought of
thinking as this exalted tool that was
consciously directed in a very a if a
then B therefore C sort of logical
spreadsheet type of format but if you
really dig into it and look at say
Thinking Fast and Slow or blink or any
of these books that examine well we
might consider intuitive decisions or
gut feel how this a conscious drives a
lot of our survival decisions thinking
is in fact a lot broader so it's not as
though what I've prized for so long
which is this very well thought to be
uniquely human I kind of doubt that but
ability to use the prefrontal cortex in
this really analytical way is not at
odds with it is not the opposite of say
meeting someone and having something in
the pit of your stomach say no mm-hmm
we don't like this guy and in fact
there's there's something to argue that
this like first gen iPod that we have in
the front of our brains is a relatively
new addition to the party the rest of
its been evolving for millennia and one
could even argue millions of years and
I've
under value that for a really long time
and I'm spending much more attention
listening to that now and I've just seen
so many benefits in doing that does that
make you uncomfortable because you can't
quantify it in the same way it makes me
less unless less and less uncomfortable
put maybe a better way I am more and
more comfortable with using things
without extremely clear labels because
you can label something without
understanding it right and trick
yourself into believing that you know
what something is just because you have
the word for it which I think happens
all the time and causes all sorts of
strife and confusion so I'm okay with
kind of trusting in the fact that by
hook or crook by some twist of fate luck
who knows seem to have evolved to get to
this point and still be around
thank rights so there's like there's
something to it as many bugs as I have
in my software like it seems to work for
something and I don't think that the the
conscious voice in my head is
necessarily the unbagged part right
maybe that's the buggiest part yeah your
your thinking brain is not always your
friend right it can get in the way I was
I was listening to your most recent
podcast with Tim urban who's like
amazing entertaining and amazing and I
love the part about when he's talking
about AI and he's sort of describing
this you know 700 page book and we're on
page 6 99 and and kind of drawing this
analogy between humans and chimps and
then humans and AI in the sense that in
the sense that like a chimp can look up
in the sky and see an airplane but he
doesn't he doesn't know it's an airplane
it's something up there and there's
nothing that you can humanly do that's
humanly possible to get that chimp to
understand what exactly that is and how
it got there right it's just not gonna
happen because
they don't have enough brain matter and
by extrapolating that to AI the argument
that AI will develop to a certain point
where us as human beings won't be able
to conceptualize what they're doing
because we just we lack the computing
power to even understand what it is
that's going on around us and I was
thinking about that and I think baked
into that there's a lesson in humility
for all of us because we walk around
thinking that we are capable of
understanding everything if we just pin
it down and think about it enough or
write it out or dissect it or
deconstruct it that we can wrap our
heads around it but in fact that more
likely than not is not the case and so
for me like on a personal level that
allows me that that that provides like
an ample place for wonder you know or
faith or for being comfortable with
things that you don't fully understand
when that when that instinct comes up or
that intuition that's telling you not to
do something you don't have to
understand it or deconstruct it but I
think it is important to heat it or to
try to validate it on some level I think
it's it's also helpful if you want to
assess a or arrive at a humble
perspective at least as it relates to
human knowledge which i think is
important so you don't make really
egregious mistakes when possible history
reading history is very helpful and when
you go back not all that far I mean you
realize are at some point in time all of
the powers that were the equivalent of
all the smartest people and the top
politicians of the day and scientists
and so on
thought that the earth that was the
center of the solar system or the center
of the universe right you have like
Ptolemaic astronomy and then Copernican
and that was heresy and then you have
people who again at the very top Rank's
thought the germ theory of disease was
complete nonsense and on and on and on
it goes and to
that we're finally we have found
ourselves in a place where no longer is
that true we've got everything figured
out is so ludicrous there's just
absolutely no historical precedent to
suggest that that is the case in fact
there's every historical precedent to
suggest that as some doctors say you
know 50% of what we know is wrong we
just don't know which 50% mm-hmm and I
think that's generous mm-hmm I've just
seen too many weird things in the last
few years especially to think that we
have even a small fraction that that we
have earned even they have 5% ability to
say that we understand an equally small
fraction of what we can perceive through
our senses I think that's and that's an
aggressive statement in and of itself
yeah I mean there's there's so much we
don't know and if you become somewhat
comfortable with that and you become a
little measured with the strong opinions
that you hold and try to ensure that
you've earned the right to have the
strong opinions it's it's hard to it for
me to envision many downsides to that so
does that help you kind of access the
gray and everything like how is that
manifested like that awareness how is
that manifested itself and how you sort
of navigate the day yeah I mean I've I'm
still very very hungry learning machine
I still love experimentation but I'm
also increasingly comfortable with just
not knowing how certain things work and
exploring them anyway and the tendency I
think for all of us is to want to come
to a place holder conclusion right like
in until I have better data I'm going to
conclude that X behaves the way it does
because of why
and I'm more comfortable now to simply
saying don't know I don't know no idea
and for instance I like debate I'm
decently good at it I also enjoy
competition based on just having
practice it for so long I hate losing
and if I have someone that's a public
event audience QA and they want to just
kick the hornet's nest and take a fight
a big mouth man yeah yeah I kick the
hornet's nest and pick a fight on any
number of a million subjects
I am totally I'm much more comfortable
now simply saying I politely decline
your invitation to argue about something
that I have no right to argue over
mm-hmm I don't have any information to
have earned an informed opinion next
question is that how would you have
handled that five years ago I would have
dismantled it or attempted to dismantle
it by just using rhetoric in questions
to make them contradict themselves and
it's not that hard to do I mean you
could easily do it is I mean you don't
have to be a trial lawyer to be good at
this play if you if you've had legal
training I find that it's very common
that lawyers enjoy the sport of debate
it's not always but I just specifically
trained for yeah I mean I have lawyers
in my family and it's like you there are
certain dinners where you just like
Jesus can we stop like we don't need to
debate about the cranberries for ten
minutes like fine you win like we don't
have to just let's move on all right
here's all the family stuff it's all
coming so so for me I used to enjoy that
sport but the side effect the really
nasty side effect of playing that sport
frequently is that you create the
illusion of knowing things that you just
don't know mm-hm or you make someone
look stupid who and I'm not trying to
make look people look stupid but if they
if they get really aggressive they want
to pick a fight publicly in a way that I
think is unproductive like I
historically have had no trouble just
like cutting them off of the knees and
I'll still do that if someone's like if
if it's if it needs to be responded to
but
if someone has an interesting idea just
because you've had more practice with
juggling logic in a way that allows you
to beat them in a debate doesn't make
them wrong and you write what I see in
that though is a is a maturation of a
sense of self right because you're
you've decoupled your self-esteem or
your proclivity to be happy from the
need to win an argument or to be right
like in recovery they say like you want
to be right or you want to be happy yeah
like and and so that drive to like well
this is competition like I have to beat
this guy because you know I that's how I
feel alive or how I feel good about
myself to make sure that on the alpha
and I'm on top here yeah and I think it
takes a you know somebody who really is
self-assured in the best way to just not
engage yeah and not feel the need that
they have to bite and I think I've also
realized that part of what I've tried to
do I should say is pause for a
microsecond I don't always succeed
between stimulus and my usual response
because my usual response is for decades
have just cumulatively made me miserable
or feel miserable so I've tried whenever
I'm like okay I think all right it's
going to fight I'm good at this
like you if you're gonna fight I hope
you're good I hope you come armed and
really well prepared because this is my
sport right like that's how I've
traditionally responded and net-net I
don't think that has been a huge level
up in my sense of well-being and inner
peace so I've tried to in case like that
ask myself even before going out like if
this happens and it happens you know
that type of thing can happen on a
regular basis what if I just did the
opposite like how can I win by how can I
win by refusing to engage more what
other options are there that are just
the opposite they might completely flop
but let me
try the opposite whatever that is or
even take winning out of it completely
yeah sure that doesn't have to be one of
the parameters I mean that what you
spoke to you right there is really you
know one of the greatest benefits of
consistent meditation practice yeah for
sure so can we talk about the retreat a
little bit sure yeah
you just went when did you finish this
ten-day retreat it was on couple weeks
ago yeah from hearing you talk about it
on Jonathan's podcast I mean it's
knotted quite intense and
transformational yeah
tend a silent retreat for those who may
not have experienced that in this case
at least had a few conditions and some
were flexible some were not no talking
10 days long so no talking no reading
discouraged from writing no music no
sense very little eye contact most
people opted not to make eye contact and
the silent piece of that the not talking
piece is by far the easiest I don't talk
to purge thoughts that's not how I do it
I do it through reading or or to
distract myself away from thought loops
I use either reading or writing
mm-hmm which in my case I didn't realize
until I had those let's take it away and
Senate retreats for the vast majority
people I've spoken to or these
revelatory ultimately blissful
experiences that teach them a lot about
themselves and then for as best I can
tell 10 to 15 percent of people who go
in who have a lot of old experiences in
particular trauma that they haven't
perhaps thought of in 20 30 years those
10 days are going to be just a descent
into Dante's Inferno and a feeling like
you are losing your grasp on reality
because
so many things are coming unwound and
bubbling up from the surface and then
just erupting through the surface in
such a way that it feels like you have
this torrent that's like waterboarding
of past pain and trauma 24/7 that you
can't stop and it got to the point for
me where on day say 7 8 9 where much to
my frustration and like tragic amusement
each day there was one exception to the
talking rule at least consistently in
the schedule there was a Dharma talk so
every night a teacher would get up and
say hey in effect here are some tools
that might help with what we're trying
to do and you're waking up at 5:30 and
the schedule from 5:30 to 9:30 outside
of meals is 45 minutes sitting
meditation 45 minutes moving to
meditation 45 minutes sitting meditation
45 minutes moving meditation that's a
rinse and repeat so that about that's it
rinse and repeat and the Dharma talk is
after let me get this right I think it's
right before dinner I may be off could
be right after noon right before dinner
I believe and it's instructional but
very often it would start with something
like the following on say day 7 it's
been so nice in our individual meetings
every other day you have about 15
minutes with a teacher to make sure
you're not going through a complete
psychotic but you're allowed to talk in
you're allowed to talk and they'll ask
you how you're doing and so let's say a
Dharma Dharma talk on day 7 teacher
would get up and say you know it's so
lovely and some of our discussions to
see how many of you are just settling
into the stillness and experiencing this
deep peace in the meantime I'm sitting
there I'm saying like going completely
insane like my my head is somewhere in
between like the cell and I think people
have seen the movie and like hostile and
like it's I mean it's not in a great
place and I'm just suffering through
this like endless repeat of past pain
that I'd thought I had long since
forgotten about or hadn't even really
remembered in so long and I genuinely
thought that I was going to
the retreat completely untethered and
unable to function it was that bad and
that was on day six or something day
seven so day six I had this experience
that was very odd I also made this
entire retreat a lot harder for myself
by doing something they strongly advised
against which was fasting for seven days
yeah so I've put in the settings I
fasted the first two days just that much
in in keeping with my historical pattern
I was like alright if I'm gonna do a ten
day silent retreat I'm probably not
gonna have a chance to write this
anytime soon so let me try to make it as
deep as possible and I fasted for two
days going into it at least roughly fast
at very low low calorie keto so then on
day three the first day of the retreat I
could be I like to 3ml molars VHB in my
blood
fantastic if that means anybody did
anybody call that you're trying to turn
this whole thing into an experiment oh
it was it wasn't enough you know I need
to worry I know well I did not
anticipate like the unraveling of Tim
Ferriss right I thought I'd be fine
because the fact of the matter is as
writer as someone who is effectively a
solopreneur I mean I have a small team
that they're all remote I spend most of
the day not talking and I was like well
this is hard can this be
gonna be hard but like it's not gonna
it's not gonna dismantle me yeah I wont
dismantle me I really underestimated
having the reading and writing removed
yeah it's like wait you just like get in
bed and turn the lights out you go to
sleep yeah how does that work oh yeah I
mean it's it's yet it was something else
so on day six I went really deep in a
number of meditation sessions in the
afternoon in particular and it coincided
with me getting out of the meditation
all I was just getting claustrophobic I
couldn't stay in there and I've had a
number of very difficult days but it
seemed in keeping with you know
sometimes they call the terrible twos or
whatever might be like the second day
third day fourth they're routinely very
difficult for people can you do any
physical exercise like you can
yeah you can there are people who were
hiking I was hiking at least once a day
during one of the moving meditation
sessions ultimately I just had to get
outside of the meditation hall i could
not sit in there for another session at
least that day and I went out I found
benches all over the property up in the
mountains and would sit and do my
meditating there and I had these very
very deep experiences where I felt like
I was going into I was going into what
you might consider a very altered state
and these parts of my body that have
carried tension for as long as I can
remember like this to the left side of
my sternum like it when I get tense or
Aang or that tense when I get angry or
overwhelmed like this is this very very
specific tension that I feel the left of
my sternum in in between the breast
plate or the the sternum and the heart
let's say and on my back which was
related to an injury I had about eight
years ago I tore my lat off my back
basically was just not something you
want to do but this this pain in my mid
back in the thoracic area and it had a
really tough time every day with the
sitting meditation I had very intense
back pain which a lot of people did now
sitting there on this bench and this
afternoon and using these tools from the
Dharma talks and various techniques that
they're recommending and it felt like I
had ice water suddenly on this that part
of my chest
and the back that portion of the back
that usually heard really odd I mean I
opened my eyes for a second because I
felt like I literally had ice water on
my chest in my back and then the tension
in both areas sort of spread out and
thinned and then dissipated and my back
no longer hurt for the first time in the
entire retreat I was like that's weird
huh and I just had this wonderful
wonderful meditation session I felt
fantastic me very joyful in certain ways
so what do you make about what I make of
that and what one of the senior teachers
made of that when I then proceeded the
next day to just completely implode or
explode or both depending on how you
look at it is that I'd finally remove
that armor and it just it allowed a lot
in and it allowed a lot out and then it
was just one Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
I mean I literally felt like I was going
insane but unlike say a strong guided
psychedelic experience there is no piece
of you at least there was no piece of me
that felt like there was an end to the
ride it wasn't as though I had some meta
awareness of being in an experience that
would end in five or six hours I just
thought that I was going to a place that
I would not recover from that's
terrifying it was horrifying and I I
will there were a few teachers but in
particular jack Kornfield who if they
had not been there I think there's a
distinct possibility that you and I
would not be talking book launch would
have been canceled none of this would
have happened I think I would have been
in a really bad place so when people
have asked me oh do you recommend it I'm
like not for everybody no I don't and
[Music]
you really need someone I think because
at least for me I didn't know what I
didn't know and I didn't even if you had
asked me like have you had trauma that
you think might come up I'd be like no
fine and in fact they did ask that
there's a questionnaire I was like I'm
good mm-hmm
I didn't know what was under the surface
because I had forgotten or repressed
I've no idea what the proper term would
be and I mean thank God for instance
Jack was there who is very well known
him he's one of five or six people I
would say accredited with bringing
Buddhist meditative practices to the
west and what's unique about Jack is
that he's not just an experienced
meditation teacher he is also PhD in
clinical psychology and has worked with
veterans who've had limbs blown off and
have PTSD he's worked with adolescents
who are cutters he's worked with many
different populations in the messy
reality of like the real world and very
real trauma not just quoting scripture
and telling you - telling you - this is
a fantastic opportunity to observe your
mind there's a there's a point where
that's helpful then there's a point
where that does nothing
but it helps you realize just how
powerful those childhood experiences are
you know it's it's reminiscent of the
work of gab or Mata like in his epic
childhood trauma and how that manifests
later in life he's there he's been on my
podcast
yeah he's fascinating guy fascinating
fascinating guy and yeah yeah so yeah
Timmy Timmy got blindsided not only like
I mean yeah I mean I'm glad you made it
out of that I'm glad Jack was there to
help guide you I also feel like there
needs to be like outpatient like some
kind of structure to help you integrate
back into the world you know once you
get out of that experience so that you
can make sense of it and and you know
take take what has been given to you in
a way that can benefit your life as
opposed to just continue to dismantle
and confuse you yeah I think this will
sound melodramatic but I I would suggest
that people maybe think about it this
way is consider it as as a thought
exercise going into neurosurgery you're
gonna go in to have neurosurgery to have
some complicated procedure performed
that usually goes right but that very
distinctly could go on it's not there is
a non-trivial likelihood 10-15 percent
that something could go catastrophic ly
sideways you want to go into that with a
the most qualified practitioner
practitioners you can possibly find on
the planet instead of feeling in a rush
and just choosing a retreat B you want
to have contingency plans what if I get
to the last day and I think that I'm
going insane right if the suture bursts
in my brain or whatever it is my analogy
what you do you just go home and go to
work the next morning right no that's
not what you do you need to have a plan
you go to New York City and you launch a
book like yeah I will say right after
the silent retreat I there were a few
intervening experiences but then I went
came straight to LA
to speak on stage at a jet somewhere at
summit conference which was complete
sensory overload but I will say that the
main thing I took out of it was not any
fixing this is important too to say I
don't think I fixed anything through the
silent retreat but I realized how how
much could be traced back to a handful
of things that I had not reconciled
within myself and that that's the work
like that's the work for me in 2018 it
is figuring out ways whether it is
through say reading up and meeting
reading up on trauma specialists and
different methodologies and spending
time with trauma specialists perhaps
you've been considering with medical
supervision something like MDMA for
instance as an adjunct therapy not a
primary that's the work for 2018 for me
and everything else is secondary mm-hmm
I mean everything else that's an amazing
realization to come out of that with a
sense of how important that priority is
for you yeah I mean nothing else matters
because you could say well what about
the people you love it's like yeah but I
can't I've realized how in completely I
can give myself to them right now
without dealing with this first mm-hmm
period and so what's the daily practice
right now the the daily practice right
now is not so much a daily practice it's
getting commitments on the calendar to
do the things that I just said or number
once that they don't get displaced by
the noise and static and the pretty cool
opportunities that float through that I
in some lapse of judgment say yes to
they need to be on the calendar so
immediately after their tree in the week
following I put things on the calendar
prepaid for them made commitments to
other people to beat certain places at
certain times so they would not get
displaced so right now it's really just
girding my loins and waiting for that
yeah you should do one of Sharon's
retreats I think it's gonna be a while
before I do another retreat but yeah I
think it would be a little bit of a
different kind of it
experience yeah yeah it might be and I
had a great wealth great people and I go
do have fun I'm like not the adjective
I'd use I had a very valuable experience
at spirit rock but it was it was very
very difficult and I think that at this
point and this is true with many
different interventions whether that's
silent retreats motivational seminars
conferences plant medicine there are it
is very seductive to get frequent flyer
miles on the interventions instead of
doing the the time and energy consuming
integration post work
yeah it's less sexy it's less sexy like
that's the real work yeah it's like okay
now I'll show you I shall show you the
direction in which you need to push the
boulder up the hall but there comes a
time when you like okay I actually just
need to put on my big girl pants and
like and do push the guy and Boulder and
yeah direction the experiences are like
the reveal of what the work needs to be
or what it's what it needs to look like
but you know I have friends I'm sure you
do too I have one friend this guy did
ayahuasca like 52 times and he or
something like that like I don't you
know god bless him I know I don't know
what that's about but at some point it
it feels like well is that helping you
or is that a distraction or a
procrastination of the work that it's
revealing yet you then go and do I don't
know the answer to that I don't have
judgment on that but I I would say in
the majority of chase in the majority of
cases or chases it might be actually
pretty good for hints live but in the
majority of cases it is a way to put off
doing the work which by the way reading
can also be which I'm shooting myself in
the foot by saying since ostensibly
we're gonna talk about but no no no but
but there there's always
if you have some degree of intelligence
or just slyness you can always find a
seemingly justifiable way to put off
doing what it is you should be doing and
as a writer I feel really qualified to
say this because most writers I know
will do anything to avoid writing I mean
it's like all the plants die well I
can't possibly sit down and work on my
new chapter if my environment contains a
dead plant I really need to fix it
didn't plan it's like oh my shoes are
dirty well I'm gonna need to get my
exercise later in the afternoon and they
need to be ready so that I'm not
distracted later so let me put off
writing and the writers will just do
anything to get out of writing and
that's human nature it's not because
writers are bad people it's not because
say somebody listening is a bad person
that they've maybe been a seminar junkie
instead of going back to the note book
they filled up and actually putting next
steps on their calendar it's human
nature but for me right now it's it's
about the work and holding myself
accountable and maybe surprisingly to
some people I am NOT a huge I don't have
a high degree of confidence in in
willpower or discipline I have a high to
be surprising to hear that from someone
like you I have a high degree of
confidence in systems and accountability
and loss aversion that creates the
illusion of discipline and willpower
right so you could take somebody let's
just say who's always had trouble losing
weight and I'm like all right I'm gonna
take photographs too you really
unflattering first thing in the morning
after you've gone on a bender and your
tighty whities in your kitchen now I own
those photos all right and they also
take 5% of your income and if you don't
lose 20 pounds in the next eight weeks
and keep it off for six months not only
am I gonna release those photographs
onto the internet post them on Facebook
everywhere your friends family
colleagues will see them I'm also going
to donate five percent of your income to
an anti charity
you would rather nuke than give money to
and you will be on the public record as
having given $5,000 to whatever it might
be you know they what who knows George W
Bush Presidential Library or the
American Nazi Party it doesn't really
matter and not sure they're of charity
but regardless you get the idea to an
organization that you would just be
endlessly shamed to be associated with
unless you lose this weight and I
guarantee you with that that why two
people figure out the how to yeah I mean
that's a pretty powerful external
motivators yeah and it doesn't have to
be that intense but I see no reason to I
see every reason to make your incentives
compelling and most people don't need
more willpower or discipline they need
better incentives so that that's either
a reward or it's some type of punishment
and the punishment could be prepaying
for say a certain number of training
sessions with an athletic trainer they
are non recoupable mm-hmm maybe that's
enough for a lot of people it is even if
they make a lot of money for some folks
the idea of losing a few hundred bucks
right will drive them insane so they
will actually show up or having someone
like working out with a friend who's
gonna bust your balls metaphorically
speaking gender-neutral whatever if you
don't show up to be their workout
partner maybe that's enough to shame you
or guilt you into doing it great use it
so in my case to ensure that I won't
lapse because I procrastinate sure I
mean there are things I'd prefer not to
do and I can find very easily justified
activities that look very sexy from the
outside and worthwhile to dodge the
things I need to do that are harder and
the way that I try to ensure I'll do
those things I put them on the calendar
I put down money I book flights I make
all the plans I hold myself accountable
other people I tell my close friends
maybe the details of
the silent retreat and spend an hour of
their time and mine explaining how
important and critical this is for me
and what I'm gonna do in December and
January and February and I know they're
gonna fight some of these crazy deals
with your friends where they have
license to you know post unsavory photos
I haven't I haven't done that but but I
would if I felt like I needed it but
just the fact that I've dropped
thousands of dollars on travel plans and
blocked out my calendar and made
appointments with various people and
made effectively promises to people in
my life
very deliberately so that I know they
will ask about it later I will be
ashamed of myself
right if I say that I bailed that's
enough for me that's that's enough to
make sure that I'll do it well I think
is dovetails pretty nicely with the new
book tribe of mentors which is great and
like you've described it as a you know
choose-your-own-adventure you can crack
it open to any page you know and spend a
couple minutes and kind of set your
intention for the day and you did a
beautiful job with it so congrats on
that I love it and you know when it when
it got delivered here and I opened it up
I was like this [ __ ] right up
700 Facebook like less than a year after
the other like what kind of robot is
this dude but then I did my own
deconstruction of it I was like oh I can
see how it I was able to do this and yet
that doesn't detract from the value of
it and which brings up this other issue
that I know is kind of forefront in your
mind this kind of marching order of
Rican Sep schewe lysing how you navigate
maybe not just your professional life
but all aspects of your life with this
mantra of you know what if it were easy
right which is it and this is like
another thing where I dovetail with you
perfectly because coming from that self
flagellation self-flagellating you know
work ethic you know you got a like if if
you if you don't feel like you've just
punished yourself to the core then you
didn't work hard enough on it and it
could be better if you just suffered a
little bit more for the benefit of the
end work product that's how I approach
everything and ultimately that's my
enemy
because it prevents me from actually
embracing you know the work and and so
this is something that that I've been
struggling with and thinking a lot about
as well that idea of like it doesn't
have to be that way like that's actually
a lie that you're telling yourself but
the idea of it being easy is so
uncomfortable it's like you know it
can't I keep telling myself that but
that is not true yeah it's it's a it's a
massive gear shift for me to ask this
question which I do a lot now the what
might this look like if it were easy one
substitution that people can use to ease
into it if they're really uncomfortable
with the easy part is what might this
look like if it were elegant so just
fewer moving pieces right so if you have
to trick yourself into trying it as an
exercise in journaling that's a good way
to do it the second piece of that is
what might this look like if it were fun
too because something can be easier but
still unenjoyable and wit and both of
those things is sound so like when you
verbalize it it just sounds so absurd
but I've spent the vast majority of my
life as someone who prided himself on
high pain tolerance in effect looking
for things that were somehow socially
rewarding that involved a high degree of
pain and a high degree of unpleasantness
and what ends up happening at least what
happened to me is I went from excelling
in areas or sports or business
approaches that were rewarding and as a
necessary tax involved pain to seeking
things that were painful which is not
which is the is is it's mistaken this
it's confusing the cause isn't in this
symptom right because you created that
imprint at an early a yeah this is the
this is how it works like if I want to
win this wrestling match here's what I
have to undergo do that and then that
gets applied to every air
right and I think where it where things
get really mixed up and then can be
tragic is many things that involve some
discomfort or pain can be productive
right but not all things that are
painful are per lead to anything
productive there and you can just become
a masochist without realizing it that's
what happened to me and I also felt like
I could grasp complexity and juggle a
lot more effectively than other people
so I was drawn to complexity because I
felt I could win there I felt like it
was a there was a high barrier to entry
mmm that gave me a competitive advantage
and yeah not sorry to interrupt I'd like
that like when I was a kid and I was
showing prowess as a swimmer I sought
out the 200 butterfly because that was
the event that no one wanted to do yeah
it's sort of like looking for that world
record that is like hidden or that just
no one feels like yeah tackling like
where's the easiest road to success well
I'll go to that one thing that's the
it's the hardest race everyone avoids it
because it's so painful that's where I'm
going right it's very similar to what
you're saying for sure
and then at some point especially in the
last year I realized I'm just fighting
an empty jacket here like who's my
competitor is this ridiculous like I'm
actually just fighting myself and what
might this look like if it were easy and
it started as a journaling exercise
which is one of the most common patterns
in all the interviews I've done and
travel mentors and Titans and the
podcast journaling meditation and
journaling are kind of the two partners
in a sense they work together really
well they recur over and over again and
says journaling one morning on what
might this look like if it were easy
well I've done it for many many
different things with respect to this
book yeah specifically you know for well
I did it for the podcast when I started
the podcast I had to ensure that there
was next to no editing
I'll do it my friends in the beginning
to make it less intimidating
I would allow wine which didn't always
turn out very well it actually really
ended poorly in the first episode in
particular but that's what you needed to
do that's why I need to do just to just
like get the lawnmower started I needed
to to to grease the skids and make it as
easy as possible and you can always
complicate it later but if you start
with the complex the likelihood of
quitting or abandoning it very quickly
is high or not meeting a deadline in the
case of the book for instance and so in
the case of this book I never intended
on writing at first of all I was just
going through this crisis of meaning and
had all these existential questions on
my mind because I turned you turn 40
which in of itself wasn't a big deal but
then the TED talk about suicide
coincided to the day which was wild
with the 10th anniversary of the 4-hour
workweek so people expected me to get up
and talk about all these blueprints for
success I did the opposite which was
surreal for me as well and then all
these deaths happen including one of the
mentors in the book Terry Laughlin who's
had a huge impact in my life passed away
a few weeks ago and that was an amazing
podcast by the way thank you I was
brutal man that was a hard one for those
people who don't know yeah I recorded
the last long form interview with Terry
before he died and he actually sounded
really good he sounded really good when
I he was in the hospital but he sounded
really good when I had him on the phone
and his daughters felt like things were
looking up and I went on the silent
really the first text I saw and I've
turned on my phone after 10 days and saw
this barrage of notifications was did
you see the news about Terry and then a
sort of crying modicon from a friend of
mine I was like oh no and I had to go
back and rerecord the introduction
because the introduction was this very
upbeat like I'm so excited to introduce
you to one of my favorite people thought
it on I had to change it all the past
tense which is brutal and all those
things led me to want to reach out to
people I respected many of
whom were further down the road right
they were 40s 50 60 70 s the best in
various fields to ask them how they had
navigated different things and when I
started reaching out to people as one
offs I realized pretty quickly that the
answers were it seemed like a missed
opportunity for me to keep them to
myself and that's how the podcast
started to big set have these
conversations over dinner with a friend
I be like god damn like this guy just
blew my mind
for two hours and it's gone right it's
just this ephemeral experience that only
I and he or she experienced and poof
never to be heard again and it's it
seemed like such a waste and I wanted to
just try recording those and similarly
when I started getting it just like you
know why not just put this in the book
and maybe it works maybe it doesn't that
was another thing that I've done the
last few years to really relieve
unnecessary pressure that has been super
helpful I'll do things but in the very
beginning I'll set the expectations with
any partners that it might not work out
and if it doesn't I'll make them whole
right and so you did yeah you did that
with this book right you told the
publisher like I'll give the advance
back yeah might not work like it's
coming together yeah if it doesn't it
doesn't come together give you the
advance back and that's now people who
are your intelligent listeners who are
paying attention may say well wait a
second Ferriss that seems like the
opposite of holding yourself accountable
right so there are but I will say there
are times when I want to apply pressure
and then there are categories of
activities in my life where I've
historically applied too much pressure
and instead of just like stressing the
organism in a beneficial way I'm just
like sitting in a tanning bed for 10
hours straight which is not helpful and
right the idea of writing a book is just
going so deep into a pain cave that you
may never resurface yeah you don't need
you don't need to add salt to the wound
like it's already going to be a
difficult slog and
for the first few books I really
punished myself unnecessarily I made it
a lot harder than it had to be and the
consequences were pretty dire I mean my
health would suffer and except for
during for our for our body I was
walking the talk for that one but for
the other books I really let myself
deteriorate and so for this one I set
the expectation okay I'm gonna give this
a shot I'm gonna try it the easy way and
if it doesn't work doesn't work give it
the advance back which which puts my
polish in a bit of a pickle I mean it
puts them in a bit of a tight position
but fortunately I had a release date for
this yeah yeah well yeah I mean
thankfully you know HMH houghton mifflin
has been very patient with me but I also
delivered on the last book which was set
up very similarly in the sense that I
wanted to try something new I'm not sure
but if it works I'm gonna know very
quickly and I will buckle down and
really get it done and then we will just
by the hairs of our chinny chin chin
Hill with the publish and print and get
everything handled but yeah and then and
then it came together so it's been um
and every time that every time something
like that like that works for me
where I take not necessarily the path of
least resistance but I don't
automatically choose the path of most
resistance and it works it helps to
reinforce me not punishing myself right
like those neural pathways yeah yeah
just like oh okay great like I don't
have to go into the gym and like
fracture every bone in my body every
time it doesn't make sense yeah see this
is I really need to learn this I'm
facing you know writing a new book and
and I'm and I'm blocked by by fear and
by that idea that inevitably this is
gonna be painful right like I've already
made that decision right and this is not
serving me right and so reframing it and
coming up with a different Avenue to
approach it I think is important so that
was that was super helpful to me to have
you to hear you talking about this so
regularly yeah one of them one of the
mantras that I've been that word bothers
me still but one of the I love your
aversion to like any word that is it
even in the slightest bill
and I think I've developed you know how
you can experience adult-onset allergy
so for instance for instance I love
eggplant and two years ago I develop
this allergy to eggplant which sucks and
it's very severe like my throat will
close up and it that that really bothers
me but nonetheless have developed this
adult and said onset allergy and I think
I also developed a San Francisco induced
adult-onset allergy to to a lot of
woowoo stuff and if for those people who
haven't seen ultra spiritual by JP
scooters on you tears oh my god just
watch that and you'll kind of get it if
you've never had the experience but yes
I'm a stickler for words in certain
words I think just carry a lot of
baggage that require a lot of lifting to
get out anyway so there's a phrase let
me use that then I repeat to myself a
lot and in the last two three years in
particular and the the phrase is don't
retreat into story so there are certain
stories we all have that we tell
ourselves and some of the stories very
very old right IMX
I can never why I always blah whatever
it is I like this is all this is going
to be painful or I always [ __ ] up
whatever there's these these stories as
short as they might be as poorly as they
might sell as a children's book these
short stories that we all have and I've
really tried in the last year and a half
or two and meditation does help a lot
with this too whether use an app like
headspace or guided meditation from
something it's a terrible core Sam
Harris or whatever or just TM or some
type of seated meditation to tell myself
and I'll put this at the top of my
journal in the morning if I'm using
something like the five-minute journal
and then all caps of the tapas but don't
retreat in the story don't retreat a
story I might even if I'm feeling myself
starting to tailspin
into some old pattern I will go into
my journal I've never talked about this
and since I know I'll be using the
journal each morning I will I will I
will put one of two things at the very
top of each journal entry for the next
say 15 days before I can forget or
procrastinator or not do it one is don't
retreat in this story the other one
which is very closely related is
actually from Tony Robbins who have
gotten to know in the last couple of
years who impresses me the more I get to
know him which is saying a lot because
frickin Tony Robinson anyway and that is
state and then an arrow to the right
story then an arrow to the right
strategy this is really important so
state leads to story leads to strategy
because what what I've noticed for
myself is that if I wake up and I'm just
in a funk didn't get enough sleep or I'm
just maybe feeling the in the the early
symptoms of maybe going into a funk for
whatever reason there are many things
that can trigger it what I'll sometimes
make the mistake of doing sitting down
and immediately trying to problem-solve
in a depressed energetic or emotional
state and what tony has explained to me
is if you do that the lens that you're
going to wear is only going to allow you
to see the problems and the negative so
you're gonna sit down you're gonna try
to you're gonna try to form a strategy
from the outset but you're going to have
a negative state a disabling story that
you're telling yourself and this
strategy is gonna be terrible yeah
you're trying to solve the problem with
the mindset that created the for all
right it began with right and instead
the the state story strategy leads me to
that's one of the things and not many
things can get me to do this so I am I'm
very much an evening exercise guy but
that has encouraged me to once again go
in the calendar and pre-booked exercise
with trainers I don't this is gonna
sound bad but like I don't need trainers
I don't never really had trainers
for what I accountability see count
abilities so I will book myself for
things that I would normally never do
like one-on-one Pilates classes oh my
god puke right like which actually done
well technically is pretty goddamn hard
it's like GST the gymnastic strength
training in a lot of respects but
nonetheless let me not defend my Pilates
have it right now but I will I will say
pre book Pilates or Accra or some type
of Olympic weightlifting in the mornings
at least say three days a week and I'll
book it out four weeks in advance
I'll prepay schedule everybody and I
know they are showing up right for me
mornings like 10:00 a.m. I know is
laughable people but like to make sure
that I am up and ready which means I
will have to wake up probably at least
nine which is just an accomplishment for
me historically gone to bed like 3 4 5
a.m. Wow which it's not help meant
minute manage manic depression by the
way and but I'll get it on the calendar
and that will set my state then I will
have an enabling story and then also the
strategies it's a very long-winded way
of explaining why I use two prompts at
the top my journal and I'll pre fill
them very honestly number one don't
retreat into Story number two a state
arrow story arrow strategy to things on
that the first thing is I have a mantra
a phrase that I use that's similar to
that which is mood follows action yeah
right which is essentially saying change
your state right like if you change if
you take an action to change your state
then you are in a better position to
tackle whatever difficulty you're in but
the idea that you're gonna try to solve
your problem in the mood in which you
know is perpetuating it is ridiculous
or the idea that yours gonna wait until
you feel like doing something in order
to feel better like that's never gonna
work but to get and the second thing is
to get back to this idea of story see
that super woowoo god picture at
black-and-white photographic well yeah
that guy it's super woowoo guru dude
like guru Penta yeah yeah he actually
he's an amazing consciousness and he was
here doing an event and he addressed
this very subject and he did it in a
very interesting way in talking about
the stories we tell ourselves about
ourselves he said imagine a branch on a
tree and every knot on that branch is
one of those stories and over time as we
mature and grow there's more knots and
we we Wed those knots we create a
narrative out of the series of these
knots and that becomes the story of your
life and for most of us we go through
our whole life without ever challenging
those stories but it's all fabrication
right it's all illusion these may be
things that happen to you your memory of
those events may be skewed but why is it
that we choose these knots as being the
defining sort of character defining
events of our lives and don't we have a
choice to choose different things that
happen to us over the course of our life
to form a brand new narrative that can
tell a different story about who we are
that then projects you know into the
future as behavioral change that could
completely you know
reshape how you live yeah and at night
it's it's a I think it's a really useful
framework for thinking about it and
furthermore out add that maybe is
alluded to with the journaling for me at
least changing the stories or creating
new stories
looks like exercise it's not a one-time
decision right it's not one and done
this is a practice
well that groove is so deep it takes a
long time to yeah you have to practice
it so I do that through journaling very
frequently and I'll have say prompts
that I'll use with I am dot dot and that
is an opportunity each morning to
practice new stories right I like that
and I found it very very valuable but
you need to use repetition like you said
their grooves are it's like you've been
playing the same
goddamn track tens of thousands of times
you need at least at least a few hundred
repetitions just to get a toehold mm-hmm
with this new story and it does have a
chance doesn't you don't need to reach
an equivalent number of repetitions
particularly since you're now
consciously directing yourself
the quality of those reps is better and
I think makes up for a lot of lost time
but you do need to take it as a practice
and for me what that means practice I'll
tell you what practice doesn't mean to
me practice doesn't mean I'll do it when
I remember to do it practice means I put
it on my [ __ ] calendar so it's not on
my calendar it doesn't exist happen yeah
getting back to the book one of the
parts of the book that's been really
helpful to me and it's spoken to me
directly is these strategies around how
to say no you know which is I just I'm
terrible at you know yeah you seem to me
to be somebody who's always been pretty
good about boundaries and I can't
imagine the opportunities that are
coming your way you know that you're
probably constantly you know being fed
and I'm sure most of them or the vast
majority of them are super cool things
that would be really fun and awesome to
do so let's talk a little bit about the
power of saying no and and how you think
about what to say yes do yeah this is a
perennial topic and it's a perennial
topic and a perennial challenge because
weather opportunities or problems let's
talk about problems for a second because
I think the comparison will be helpful
there are many people who think and I've
certainly thought at different points in
my life if I just do X or achieve Y my
problems these problems will all go away
and what you realize is as you continue
on this journey that is often meandering
called life you don't get rid of your
problems if you achieve certain types of
success you just trade up so maybe you
had like you know the
the corolla of problems then you trade
up and you've got like the use mercedes
of problems and you trade up and you
have whatever the porsche of problems
the the magnitude and complexity can can
become really challenging and the
opportunities become themselves problems
in the sense that and many people
listening might say come on give me a
break like this is such a I wanna career
like well I got like I get 1% or
woe-is-me story but it's not and I'll
tell you why because thank you very much
in in the very very very beginning of
your career
I do think yes as a default can be very
helpful but when I say the very very
beginning I mean literally maybe 1 to 2
years out of college if you go to
college you don't have to go to college
but let's just from my personal
experience once you have an even a vague
glimmer of a notion of what you're
really good at versus what you're bad at
and once you have a semi-decent
group of friends and colleagues and
co-workers the birthday parties the
going out for drinks the conferences
that may or may not piss away three four
days of your life these start to appear
and they hear the siren song and my
experience that the the when I've
encountered stagnation in my life or
felt overwhelmed for the most part
sometimes it's due to you know
catastrophe and huge problems but very
often it's because I have over committed
to the kind of sort of cool stuff and
then my calendar is so crowded you know
as Derek Siver's who's one of my
favorite entrepreneurs would say also
just an incredible sort of philosopher
king of programming and a just eccentric
guy and the best way possible you know
he would say
that if it if it's not a hell yes it's a
no all right now that's at a very high
level that's helpful but then you have
to translate that to strategies and
tactics right but I do think that before
you can say no effectively there are a
few assumptions or first principles that
are really helpful to accept at least
for me because for instance everyone or
not everyone but a lot of people have
heard of in boxes zero and that's just
never gonna yeah it sounds like a good
idea but where you at what what ends up
happening if the inbox is everybody
else's agenda for your time and it's
asymmetric or it's very easy for people
to send email very time-consuming to
respond particularly if if you're
receiving more than you're sending so if
you look at my top left right there yes
three hundred and seventy three thousand
one hundred fifty are those unread
completely or like you read on but you
just simply leon's you haven't even
looked at them have not even so why even
have like that email account I mean what
did you know it's it's it's going to me
so I let you concentrating more and more
secret secret behind the velvet rope
email address there is that yeah but I'm
also this we ride on digress we could
certainly go into crazy tech conspiracy
land but if you want to talk about
creepy there's a lot of creepy stuff
that's been happening with recent
upgrades related to Apple and Google as
far as I'm concerned and I do know a lot
of people in tech but when I upgraded my
well this version of iOS
I had no mail set up and it's somehow
and I certainly not input these changes
determined that I suppose through
communication my assistants account
should be automatically set up for
notifications on my phone through mail I
did not manually go like password and
everything yeah so that's super I
consider that very creepy yeah
so part of the reason I'm diversifying
my digital identity in certain ways but
the the point being if you even decide
to respond politely to all inbound there
will come a point if you achieve 20%
what you hope to achieve that becomes
untenable I think in left unless you
have people sending you snail mail or
something maybe that becomes manageable
but one of the most important principles
for me that that has helped me to say no
more effectively this is a principle
right we're gonna get into the more
nitty-gritty is that to achieve there
are really big good things you are going
to have to let a a lot of small
recoverable bad things happen no way out
and also recognizing a few other things
that have been very helpful that and
this is I think it's Herbert's whoa or
swoops who is the first recipient I
believe the Pulitzer Prize and I'm
paraphrasing here be said roughly I
can't give you one recipe for success
but I can give you the recipe for
failure and that is trying to please
everyone all the time
also lip service people have heard some
variation of that before but the the
paired quote that I think of a lot is
from dr. Seuss this is what Ted Geisel
which was the people who matter don't
mind and the people who mind don't
matter mm-hmm so if you don't reply to
someone in a day or two and they get
really really really pissed off I hate
to say it but like that the people who
have a lot of [ __ ] going on themselves
and now they understand they get it so
those are all just like operating
principles then when we get down to
strategy you have on the simplest level
not responding outside of autoresponder
and so if we're looking at email it's
usually the most egregious offender you
can set up autoresponders that indicate
policies and it's so something you might
have something along the lines of
you're all I'm only able to respond to
email directly related to projects I
currently have on deadline unfortunately
I'm not physically capable of replying
to all the email that I receive due to
cold intros and so on which also gives
people a little [ __ ] slap if they're
doing cold intros without asking first
below are the answers to 80% of the
email I receive mmm subject number one
I'm not doing any book blurbs of any
type for close friends family or
otherwise zero number two like I'm not
doing any more startup investing of any
type ABC here so here's a link to an
article that explains why and so on and
so forth then it just requires the
discipline to not reply even if
someone's like hey I just want to check
in it's like yeah I know you got my
outer sponsor then then when you're
responding I mean part of the one of my
greatest that greatest it's not great in
in the sense that I am great but one of
my happiest realizations when I was put
any other Trevor mentors was as I got
these rejection letters these polite
declines from people who are too busy to
be in the book got one from Wendy
MacNaughton is a very famous illustrator
and it was so good it was so beautifully
brilliantly crafted that I loved her
more afterwards than I did before
keeping in mind I just been rejected
like very clearly rejected but it was so
deftly done and I was bummed out I was
bummed out for a little bit and then I
remember I was with my my researcher
sitting there and I think we might have
had some wine and I said wait a second
you know be really funny as if I
included the rejection letters because
we're talking so much about how to say
no and asking people how to say no and
we paused for a second then I realized
wait a minute why don't I just ask one
day if I can include yeah it's right
here like you can read that but yeah so
she ends up in the book and yes with her
permission I'm not printing anything
without anyone's permission but anything
that she did not be in the book I ended
up I ended up including a number of
these rejection letters
that I thought were very very well done
and there are criteria that well done
well done rejections check such as it's
not a punt it's not hey I'm so busy
right now I just can't get it like maybe
sometime soon like two three months when
really they just want to say no and then
I put it in my calendar and fall out for
three months and it wasted everybody's
time yeah being a people pleaser like I
make that mistake all the time which
which I've also been guilty of right but
this this is the this is the email very
very Wendy so I included other examples
from saying Neil Stevenson wrote Snow
Crash and krypton nomicon this
incredible incredible fiction writer
another from Danny Meyer who's Reggie
legendary restaurant or shake shack and
many many others different styles right
so you have to find one that fits your
personality but you can borrow language
and I'll point out some of the things
that I borrowed from hers hers is really
extensive because we know each other
quite well and and so on but here it is
very much suited to her personality
alright hi Tim gah okay I've been
battling with this and here's the deal
after five intense years of creative
output and promotion interviews about
personal journeys and where ideas come
from
after years of wrapping up one project
one day and jumping right into promoting
and other to the next dot dot dot I'm
taking a step back I recently maxed out
pretty hard and for the benefit of my
work I got to take a break over the past
month I've cancelled contracts and said
no to new projects and interviews
alright so I want to point this is Tim
commentary I want to point out this is
very common in these good polite
declines that they're making it clear
it's a policy across the board and then
it's not personal right that may or may
not be true but at least the delivery is
that it's a policy back to nd I've
started creating space to explore and
doodle again to sit and do nothing to
wander and waste a day and for the first
time in five years I'm finally in a
place where there's no due date tied to
every drawing no deadlines for ideas and
it feels really right here's another
commonality that's coming up so while I
really want to do this with you I
respect you and your work and I'm
honored that you'd asked me to
participate and his capital as stupid as
it is for me professionally not to do it
I'm going
have to say thank you but I got a pass
so another commonality is that people
will say you know I know I'll be kicking
myself later I'm sure that's gonna be a
huge success but just for my sanity or
my health I have to apply lis decline
this another thing that comes up a lot
is people will say something along the
lines of I would love to do this but
what you would get out of me will be so
subpar mediocre compared to what I might
be able to give with a future project I
want to decline both the both just for
my for my own benefit but also because I
think you'll get better results from
other people all right
and she says I'm simply not in a place
to talk about myself for my work right
now crazy for a highly verbal only child
to say hopefully we'll get a chance to
talk somewhere down the line I promise
any thoughts I'll have for you then will
be far more insightful than anything I
can share with you right now
I hope the space created by my absence
is filled by one of the brilliant people
I suggested in my previous email and
really thank you so much for your
interest I'll be kicking myself when the
book comes out and Wendy and she did
send suggestions for other people and a
number of them ended up being in the
book including the very first profile
Cimino Scott who is an incredible chef
that is one hell of a great write
decline but very different from from
like Seth Godin who would just say yeah
I can't do it yes sorry another thing on
some level like she's she's going into
you know quite a bit of depth into
explaining why she can't do that's right
which might which might fatigue other
people I think you didn't have a
relationship with her already that's
right I think that is reserved if I had
to guess that's reserved for people she
knows right because it doesn't it
doesn't scale very well but it really
serves a purpose with the relationships
that you value and as a contrast
I'll read Danny Meyer's Danny Meyer is
the founder and CEO of Union Square
Hospitality Group which includes many
restaurants Gramercy Tavern the modern
maialino Shake Shack etc all right
fascinating guy really really smart did
away with tipping in a bunch of his
restaurants as a policy for a bunch of
reasons
with fascinating rationale behind us a
real innovator in the food and beverage
world all right so here's his which was
sent to my friend who tried to get the
job done
who's super effective my buddy Jeffrey
who helped a lot in the 4-hour chef nice
so he asked Danny because he knows Danny
and this is Danny's response to my
friend Jeffrey Jeffrey comma greetings
and thanks for writing I'm grateful for
the invitation to participate in Tim's
next book project but I'm struggling at
this moment to make time make time ends
meet for all we're doing at us Hg that's
his business group including my ongoing
procrastination with my own writing
projects I thought carefully about this
as it's clearly a wonderful opportunity
but I'm going to decline with gratitude
no the book will be a big success
exclamation point
thanks again Danny right so that's very
short yeah and I want to highlight one
line that you can just copy and paste
right like you don't have to reinvent
the wheel and that's that's what's been
so fun for me about realizing how little
effort needs to go into this when you
find something that works it's like you
just used the same language so this line
I've used a lot you know I thought
carefully about this Sutan that's a
really key phrase right it's not just I
don't like you
sounds stupid it's like no I actually
thought about this like I thought about
I thought carefully about this is it's
clearly a wonderful opportunity but I'm
going to decline with gratitude period
that's a really powerful gentle way to
do it and there's so many ways that I've
been rejected and continued to be
rejected and you can take stuff from it
I remember you know I've been turned
down even early on by Seth Godin for
stuff by who else I mean got a list is
really really really really long Guy
Kawasaki but they did it really well for
a guy at one point declined something
and this was just a year or two ago
couldn't make it where he's like sorry
just can't make this work alright so you
can be very brief and in some cases
that's better because you don't want
people to try to counter and then you
end up in an email just change I like
yeah like now I'm gonna have to have
five emails
just being lakum email with exactly so
my preferences do not respond whenever
possible the only way to receive fewer
email is to send fewer email basically
and I'm a Robert Scoble who's Sofia a
perennial figure in the tech world who
really helped with the tipping point for
the 4-hour workweek in the very
beginning and he did the math at one
point because he was getting bashed by
so many email he was he was a certainly
perceived then and still is as an
influencer who can really move the
needle and he said I've realized doing
the math that for every email I send I
get one point seven two in response that
doesn't just you don't have to be a
mathematician to realize that is not
favorable to sending more email in any
case so the guy said to me hi Tim sorry
I just can't make this work right now
I'll have to raise a glass from the
sidelines and cheer you on guy right
that's just great
so he's he's being supportive but he's
being clear yep creating a healthy
boundary indeed is something I found
very helpful going back to the policy or
categorical decline which i think is
very helpful there are a number of ways
to do it so you can say you know just
across the board I'm doing a for my
sanity data you can say for a B and C
reasons it doesn't really matter what
the reason is by the way this is they've
done all sorts of interesting
psychological studies where they'll have
say and a Confederate or someone
involved with the experimenter go up to
get in line in front of somebody for a
copier say at an office and they'll say
I'm sorry and I really just need to use
the copier I'm in a rush or whatever
even they wouldn't say I'm in a rush
versus like I really have to use the
copier because and what came after
because didn't really matter it's like
because my dog is really loud today
because there was it because exactly
there was a reason so that I think that
also works in declines right so be like
do to a B and C or a and B I'm following
a strict this is one that I've used a
lot because I was turned down by a
famous investor for a lunch meeting and
I know him really well and he's like
sorry I'm following a really strict no
meeting diet for the next month
just to like catch up on everything that
I've
slide behind which I realize that I've
much rather take meetings and drink
coffee and like [ __ ] then do the
stuff I really seems like wow that's a
really chose phrase a no
fill-in-the-blank diet so I started
using that like a no I'm sorry I'm on a
no conference called diet for the next
month and people wouldn't even question
it except it's amazing so you can do
that that works really well I think this
idea of no you know how to say no
effectively and do it in a healthy way
yeah it extends so much further beyond
how we navigate email especially as you
know we're in this period of time where
it's just it's impossible to be bored
like we're so inundated with stimuli and
it's it's so tempting to you know see
what's going on on Twitter and if it's
not Twitter its Instagram or at snapchat
or it's this or it's that and it's like
before you know it it's 4:00 in the
afternoon and you're like all I've been
doing is looking at timelines like it's
insane alright and how do we you know so
this the saying no has to be applicable
to all manner of you know behaviors and
and thought patterns in order to like
you know do what Cal Newport would call
like the deep work like how do you how
do you cut out the noise you know make
those decisions about where you want to
invest your time and like adhere to them
so that you are actually doing what
you're supposed to be doing
oh yeah and in the case of digital tools
and screens and social media like every
per almost every person listening this
is gonna be so woefully outmatched by
companies that are spending billions of
dollars to do exactly what you hope to
avoid which is losing your focus I mean
that they're spending billions of
dollars of R&D to ensure that you never
maintain focus for terribly long because
that is how they're economically
incentivize so let me give to two tools
that have helped me one is just a tech
trick and then one is a mental framework
that I found super super helpful so the
tech trick actually comes from Whitney
Cummings is a really well-known comedian
and writer director in tribal mentors
and she learned this from blanking on
who
but a researcher who used to work at
Google and it's turning your phone to
greyscale mm and if you it's it's wild
how much of an effect this has I was
very skeptical I was like really like
I'm gonna cut back on my use of social
media by changing it to greyscale you
can find how to turn your phone to
grayscale in a million different ways
just search turn to greyscale and then
the model of your phone button I have
one it's super super simple and I would
say for myself and also readers who have
tried this based on feedback on social
the irony right that they they are using
social I'm certainly using social say
thirty to forty percent less just by
changing my photo to greyscale and
what's the psychology behind that it's
just not as like it's it's not pinging
your dopamine receptors yeah it was just
like some neurological mmm like how much
I wonder if people were dieting if they
just had like the equivalent of Google
glass and could switch it to greyscale
they'd stop would they would they not
overeat as much I suspect probably
actually they would eat less if they saw
their food and great skill right it's I
don't know the the neurological basis
for it but kind of intuitively makes
sense to me the so that that's one
really easy trick that you can use the
second is a framework for saying yes or
no to things and that I found really
helpful I use all the time Kyle Maynard
is also in tribe mentors is a a quad
congenital quad amputee what that means
is he was born without arms and legs
effectively his arms and mid upper arm
and his legs and around the hip mm-hmm
nonetheless he's in the National
Wrestling Hall of Fame number one
so like wrap your head around that yeah
wrestling fully able-bodied people he
was pinned and beaten every match his
first season people were calling it
child abuse and just crucifying his
parents then he started to win then he
started to dominate and people called an
unfair advantage the same b-boy and
wrestle in college like how far did he
take how far did he go yeah that's a
really good question I don't know
exactly how far he went I mean he can
still wrestle I know
most snap me in half when I wanted demo
and I say okay yeah that's enough I'm
clearly I'm gonna get injured and that I
wrestled like I was a pretty good
wrestler and he also I just hope people
have a little bit about of background
again something to think about so he is
the first quad amputee without the aid
of prosthetics to climb to the summit of
Mount Kilimanjaro
there are able-bodied athletes who have
died climbing Mount Kilimanjaro he
military crawled the whole [ __ ] thing
to deposit ashes of a friend who passed
away at the summit the guy's a stud and
he spends a lot of time with thanked
Special Forces folks and all sorts of
fascinating CEOs and he was given this
recommendation from a really high-level
CEO and it was when you're considering
an opportunity and invitation maybe a
perspective hire could be anything could
even be an entree at a restaurant if you
want to ask the server this question it
actually works really well rate it from
one to ten you can't use a seven mm-hmm
and I've been using this pretty much
every day since I got this explanation
from Kyle because he said the seven is a
very slippery can a non-committal
semi-cool value that he found
correspondent two things he felt he had
to do out of obligation or guilt or fear
of missing out one of the greatest ways
five years from now ten years from end
up in a place you're really unhappy with
is to let those be your drivers right
however if you take seven out six you
can't justify doing a six that's a
barely passing grade that's a no yeah so
it turns a gradient into a binary it
turns a gradient into a binary and I've
been using that for all sorts of things
now it's been great and instead of
making another thing I've tried to do a
lot in the last year and did a company
off site which is a fancy way of saying
got like three people together in one
place three or four people to focus on
what categories to say yes to or
evaluate and what categories to say no
to so that it's not one-off yes or no
one did
without seven instead of making a
million one-off decisions like
categorically for instance speaking
engagements I basically do no speaking
engagements that aren't going to give me
something evergreen I can then share
with millions of people so for instance
it's like tonight I'm gonna be on stage
and I'm gonna interview Terry Crews and
that'll be recorded you can use that and
that was on the podcast but getting up
and giving the same talk to small groups
of people over and over again
I basically stopped doing all of it I
really don't do that anymore
because as seductive as it is and
there's there's money to be made I found
it it wasn't getting me closer to my
personal mountaintop right and for those
people who find themselves maybe
procrastinator saying yes to a lot of
sevens there's a commencement speech you
have to see I'd be surprised if you
haven't seen this but there are a
million commencement speeches out there
neil gaiman 'he's make good art is so
good and you can find it online it's
very easy to find but Neil Gaiman who's
just the Ober polymath of fiction
writers the guy does everything he has
the most hypnotic voice imaginable also
go watch make good art that commencement
speech and I just realized that you know
a lot of these categories can be
eliminated altogether and if it's scary
to eliminate them you just make it a
short term trial run so maybe saying I'm
never doing speaking engagements again
for the rest of my life that's too much
of a commit that that's more of a
commitment than even I want to make for
this year maybe that's too big okay
let's try for a month see what the
father is like no matter how appealing
something seems just say no for a month
and then we'll reassess in four weeks
and see how you feel
this is a new thing for me to not what
do the balance and the balances and the
accounts look like right not the
spreadsheet like how do you actually
feel about it like are you glad you did
it or are you stressed out that you did
it
super E is it's not easy but it's binary
and feel good great let's do it another
month I like that I like that and you
know on this idea of of what if it were
easy you know you're doing this book
launch tour right now you're traveling
around all these you know press
obligations etc the podcast is still
going on and then you just watch a new
podcast like I look at that like for me
to get like one or two episodes up a
week of this like it's a lot it's a
living with help so I was like oh my god
another pot like how do you have you
automated that or like how does that
like I would just be completely stressed
yeah so I can explain this is actually a
really good example I think to tie in
everything we've talked about or a lot
of it alright so one podcasts done well
at least takes a lot of psychic energy
and time time I mean it's it's to do
anything wrong I mean takes a degree of
focus that has an energy cost so the Tim
Ferriss has been been going now for a
few years started off as a six episode
test and when people come up to me now
on the street I mean nine times out of
ten it's it's probably even more than
that it's like nineteen times out of 20
they talk about the podcast no mention
of the books which is on one hand really
exciting and one hand kind of depressing
but nonetheless that that's it and I
asked myself if I were to launch a
podcast as a way to draw attention to
the book what might it look like because
I suspect and I don't know for sure but
just based on observing charts for a
long time now that there is a there is a
high there is a high degree of reward on
iTunes at least for frequency frequency
of episodes and rate of new subscriber
rate of new subscribers so what if I
launched a new podcast same title as the
book tribe of mentors which effectively
because I don't have an audio book
version since audio book versions by the
way don't count towards the bestseller
lists mm-hmm so why would you want to
split your sales you can always come
later what if I effectively dripped out
the audiobook version visa via new
podcast and put out one a day well if I
look at my current workflow for a tim
ferriss show where i have two to four
hour and
is that's just not never an I'm
physically possible
maybe it's physically possible that I
have to drop the entire book lunch to do
just that
okay what might it look like if it were
easy well I could look at my eleven
questions which are in the introduction
of the book I can read those questions
and I could read the introductions of
people who agree to read their own
profiles and then my questions could be
spliced in to each episode and then just
have every every one of these people
that you interviewed read their own
responses that's right and I'll just
mail them all the exact same mic if they
miss you're actually sending them the
equipment sending them the equipment
they need and it's good still like a
logistical thing to oversee it's a
little but what I have to do in that
case figure out I just have to figure
out the recipe and then for people who
hear the world algorithm techies throw
it around like it's some super
complicated magical thing it's really
just a recipe it's a it's a series of
steps things that are executed to
produce a predictable result so if I can
do that and I've spent a lot of time and
I mean this first realization came about
you know around the formulation of the
4-hour workweek and learning all the
lessons that went into that but if you
can do it we all like to think we're
uniquely capable that no one could say
check our inbox for us but the fact the
matter is we do whether they're sloppy
or organized follow certain rules and
habits when we check our own inbox for
instance you can train someone to do a
lot of that certainly when it comes to
soliciting or incur asking people if
they want to opt in to record an episode
that I will promote potentially to
millions of people that will only take
them 10 to 30 minutes and I will send
them the equipment and the deadline is
fairly flexible I can teach someone else
like an assistant or a researcher to
help me execute that very easily so I
just had to I templatized the emails
that would go out in a Google Doc mm-hmm
and then that combined with Evernote
provided all the tools needed via slack
channel dedicated to this new podcast
Thank You van used and and I got Mike's
coming by FedEx coming and going and you
got Mike's flying out to be blooney of
them and then but but it's it goes even
beyond that one of the most important
things that they did in the very first
episode is that gave myself an out this
is what I mean and I think everybody
should do this when they start podcast
by the way give yourself the gracious
exit option first episode I did what I
didn't well I actually also did this for
the Tim Ferriss show I said hey this is
an experiment if it sucks I'm gonna stop
if you guys hate it a probably stop I'm
gonna do six episodes this is before
there were seasons of podcasts all of a
sudden people are coming out seasons
like hmm that's a curious idea yeah so
decide look at that and I'm like there's
lazy but there's a but they're smarter
than there's a genius in it because then
you can say seasons done huge success
now I'm gonna stop right as opposed to
Jesus Christ isn't working it's really
tiring I'm gonna stop so in the travel
interest podcast episode one I said this
is this is a season one it's gonna run
for 10 to 15 episodes what is 10 to 15
episodes equate to it equates to the
first two weeks of launch coming out
with one episode every day so the tribe
mentor is podcast has been last I
checked I mean it was number one yeah
it's like several days and it's been the
top five it's been in the top five
podcasts of all the podcasts on iTunes
for almost a week and a half now maybe
two weeks and then I'm gonna get to 15
or whatever it is and I'm done and guess
what what might this look like if this
were easy it would also look like short
episodes that I can combine into longer
episodes to use on the Tim Ferriss show
that has sponsorships and everything
else and yeah and it also ties back to
even the book like the tribe of mentors
what does tribe of mentors do among many
other things for me and the readers what
does it also accomplish which was a bit
of an late discovery on my part but I
realized half of the people in the book
would be almost impossible to get on the
podcast if the ask
you're undercutting yourself I think I
think most of those people in there
would probably do your show
it might take a while to get the skill I
will tell you I'm not gonna name names
but a lot of people in that book I
rejected or not objected politely
decline to be on the pod kaha I see so
then you kind of come back to but now I
come back with a supers wealth
relatively speaking compared to two to
four hour interview that has to be
scheduled and have calendars meshed and
so on a lightweight request to answer a
few questions to be in this book now
many of them are have seen the response
to the book right which has been
tremendous is found out today and it's
number one Wall Street Journal business
book in the first week which is exciting
thank you and so now they're like yeah -
yeah exactly so they've seen they didn't
they did I'm not gonna say next to
nothing because a lot of them put a
tremendous amount of time into their
answers I mean I mentioned Terry Crews
his answers just blew me away he really
got into it and gave really really deep
answers but lightweight compared to
doing a long podcast now that they've
seen the return on investment from the
profiles I have a hundred and forty
people who are primed to be on the
podcast and that saves me a tremendous
amount of effort over the next year and
what might this look like if this were
easy book to her well I you know what I
and what might this look like if it were
fun well one of the things I've done in
the past which doesn't make anybody
happy at least of which myself is
getting up in an event to talk about
myself in the book that people have
already bought to attend the goddamn
event it's so stupid and it's boring for
people I mean maybe it's not boring
people seem to have had fun with it but
if I'm asked myself what might this look
like if it were easy and what might this
look like I've ever fun it would be me
on stage interviewing someone like Terry
Crews to get material that's not in the
book to record it to then put it on the
podcast fantastic and yeah that's that's
ingenious yeah yeah so that's that's how
I'm thinking it's still like a lot of
work though I mean I'm still like what
you know what's a day like it
how do you get through the day managing
all the I mean you got people working
with you helping you and you systematize
this stuff to a certain extent but
there's still like staying on top of
like okay what's do what's going up
when's that happening all that like
that's there's a good amount of stuff I
will say that for a book launch for
instance 90% of the work is the book
itself because in in today's world you
might be able to game the system if if
you want to use the black arts there's
all sort of funny all sorts of funny
business that people use with book
launches it's crazy I mean including
things that I would call book laundering
all sorts of trickery that you can use
to trick people for say a week but
that's about it if your book sucks it's
toast I mean it's just not gonna last
it needs to stand on its own two feet
and so the vast majority it's no mistake
for instance that this book with the
pull quotes they're almost all now it's
antiquated in a sense because I guess
it's two hundred and eighty characters
now for Twitter but almost all these
pull quotes are gonna be less than 140
characters that's not a mistake right
easily tweetable yeah exactly
and but also the content itself and
meaning in that in the nitty-gritty of
the chapters and then the like eight
percent now we're at 98 percent right
then eight percent is planning for
months in advance not necessarily what
you're going to do but what you're not
going to do so I'll do a review of the
last launch and see what pulled its
weight and what did not and
categorically no to almost everything
for instance Facebook live in almost
every case no will I promote your
Facebook live no unless you give us
advertiser access we can get into the
Nitty Gritty but it's like no we didn't
see any return and you want us to
promote the interview that I'm doing on
your platform no that defeats the whole
purpose of being on and that's always a
weird thing yeah and what I've noticed
that were bouncing all over the place
but it's like with with I have not said
people may not believe this but I have
literally not sent out a single email to
anyone in that book saying could you
please promote mmm
zero because my assumption is I've sent
them all copy they're doing it because
they want the promotion yeah or I mean
hopefully they like the book too but
it's like I sent them all inscribe books
that I spent a lot of time on and that's
it and my assumption is if they really
like it so that they would be
comfortable sharing it they'll share it
mm-hmm right if they're not comfortable
sharing it and I try to in any way
pressure them into it it's gonna create
is easy yeah and it's gonna create a
discomfort that [ __ ] things up later
right it's like I'm playing the long
game and maybe I want to have them on
the podcast later okay doing that is in
it jeopardizes them and lasts like maybe
I could get them to promote but they're
not totally into the book that's also a
long term loss so I just let it ride
this is what I did with the last book
too and fortunately I mean people been
super super stoked but in any case I
don't want to get into all of all of
that stuff but yeah what would this look
like if it were easy I mean I'm thinking
for the next book I might just I mean
who knows maybe but like I have a couple
of book ideas in my head which is just
my addiction to masochism I guess and I
might just give them away for free
honestly he's sort of like what James
Altucher does doesn't it yeah yeah
getting my way a lot of books yeah I
mean as long as I didn't allow that to
give me permission to lower the quality
mm-hmm which i think is a is a is a
tricky temptation if you're doing giving
my stuff for free but it's like you know
the most important thing I've ever
written I think is a free blog post that
I spent months on which was the some
practical thoughts on suicide in tough
tough but post most difficult thing to
publish I've ever published but you know
that was free took me months to get done
so we're you you know you mentioned
earlier like the personal mountaintop or
the summit like you know what is that
for you like where are you taking all
this we're we're just adventure heading
Tim Ferriss I don't know and that's part
of the excitement for me
I I really don't know what I do know I
don't know where I'm going and not to
I'll pull out another way of cliche but
the attribution I don't have maybe you
do but not all who wander are lost like
I'm actually enjoying exploring right
now in what is to me very new territory
that for some people they've lived with
their emotions and experienced and
explored them and felt them for their
whole lives it's not true for me so this
is this is a brand new terra incognita
for me what are the people closest to
you saying you about this like are they
noticing a change yeah yeah they're
everyone who's really close to me
without any prompting from me without
knowing anything about the silent
retreat or whatever will sit down with
me for dinner or something and they'll
say what's going on with you not a bad
read they're just like there's something
different about you what's going on and
I feel really good so I'm happy I'm more
than happy right now and it's not a
trade but if we if we looked at it that
way I'm completely happy it elated to
trade knowing the destination for just
feeling good and that's where I am right
now
and I will say also that almost all of
my most if you were to look at it from a
professional standpoint like my most
incredibly critical professional
opportunities and decisions have come
from slack in the calendar right so
they're the the must do things that are
important like we talked about that for
instance some of these things that I put
on the calendar for the next month or
two but beyond that because that's the
most important thing beyond that after
something like this a book launch or a
TV show launch or whatever might be I
leave a lot of the calendar open because
I cannot whatever I might plan I assume
cannot take into account this the
incredible and fascinating things and
people that will
out of the woodwork as a result of say
mm-hmm I'll launch like this so I just
create the space for that all of my best
investments if you look at like Twitter
Facebook Boober Alibaba all this stuff
they all came from gaps in the system
yeah not through some crazy grand design
yeah whiteboarding how this is gonna go
no no I mean if it's it's from me and I
had a conversation with Tim O'Reilly
recently on my podcast which was so much
fun for people who don't know him you
can check him out he's he's uh
considered or he's been nicknamed the
trend spotter in Silicon Valley a really
good guy and he spends a lot of time
just sitting in stillness and just
listening and yeah that's either gonna
make some semblance of sense to people
or it's not I won't try really dig into
but through meditation and other things
he's for instance on his one habit that
his most positively impacted his life in
the last year so is on his morning runs
he goes running every morning he makes
it a point every morning he goes on a
run to stop and take a photograph of a
flower mmm yeah and that's an example of
just like stopping and experiencing some
stillness and then he'll just pause for
a second then continue on his run and
I'm sure I think I've spent so much time
yelling at myself internally for so much
of my life there was very little
stillness and now I'm taking time and
look I still have my monkey mind I still
have [ __ ] that bounces around in my
skull and when I sit down and meditate
for those people who might be wondering
like if I meditate for 20 minutes I'll
take 19 minutes of that it's just like
to-do list porn stupid argument
imaginary hypothetical discussion I
might have it's just nonsense
and then there are like 30 seconds from
like oh this is possible like this this
state of stillness is actually possible
however brief and learning to instead of
constantly yelling at myself just like
pause and I was walking through
Washington DC a couple of days ago in
during this crazy time
launch with a back-to-back insane
schedule and going to an event with an
eight hundred or thousand people and and
I this out is another thing I've never
done before I've been reading and
certain poetry it's precisely because it
does not have an explicit purpose I want
to develop it I want some serious
counter-program not like I want to do a
tolerance for that and I came across
I've tried all sorts of poetry and
almost all of it I've ended up rejecting
like I either like don't get it I just
don't get it or it's too flowery or
whatever and then I found in English
most people say how Fez HAF I see it was
born about a hundred years after Rumi
who people may have heard of hilarious
this guy's hilarious like some of his
poetry is so funny and so I've made it a
habit I've been traveling with this book
which is heavy but I wanted a paperback
and reading one poem a night basically
and so I read one before I left the
hotel on it and it talked about in
effect just paying attention to
stillness and the small sounds that make
you feel better and I was like hmm okay
well like as I kind of intend to try but
mentors to be it's like all right I want
using the poetry to just have a lens or
a question or an idea that I can then
put on and walk with for a few hours for
the rest of the day so I did that I'm
walking through DC and shits going
bonkers and they're like cars blocking
off streets because such-and-such
muckety-muck is driving down chaos
people seem pretty grumpy and then there
was this tree I walked by just full of
these birds with this incredible bird
sign right and I was I was fairly
agitated like coming into it because I
was sleep-deprived it's it's a very full
week and it's paused for like 15 seconds
there's no downside to that just like
and listen these birds back alright
despite all the [ __ ] going on right
now and all the noise there's
this in the middle of the city and it
just that like one degree changed my
state enough that then you telescope out
an hour later after walking another mile
get to the venue and I'm in a really
good mood mm-hmm yeah that's all it took
so I'm trying to pay more attention to
this tiny little gaps of stillness
instead of just continuing to yell at
myself which has overall its produced a
handful of wins but it's done a lot more
damage not sustainable yeah I just
thought of the title for this podcast
like Tim Ferriss on Tim Ferriss on on
why poetry will save your life it's yeah
and I think one thing I'd like to
underscore because I'm sure there are
people out there and if I had to guess I
would say a lot of them are probably
super driven aggressive 20-something
males and in a state of hormonal nirvana
because they're just like coursing with
testosterone and everything else it'll
just allow them to run through walls
seemingly without any damage I would say
that what I'm talking about is not
mutually exclusive from like the
aggression and the winning in the
competition like you can actually have
both you don't have to choose what
that's the thing that scares so many
people they think if I start doing that
I'm gonna lose my edge or that thing
that I've imagined that I've decided is
the thing that gives me an advantage and
allows me to do what I do in the world
yeah that's why a lot of a lot of my
friends haven't tried meditation because
they're if they're just there I came in
and I'm really I'm worried that I'll
lose that edge it's the wording that's
the exactly winning that you it's like
I'm worried I'll lose my edge and I
won't be able to get it back I gave up
two laxatives well if I accept too much
I'll become complacent now the
counterpoint to that you could put it
really you could put like a
Machiavellian lens on that and say
imagine yourself in a negotiation and
it's very tense and this person puts
something
the table that offends you and you have
that extra second to reflect and be
present and to like gauge how you're
gonna respond to that I mean that is
like a tactical advantage if there ever
was one
oh yeah I mean there there are there
definitely tactical advantages and I
will say that if you if you do a bunch
of meditation and we would stuff like
there are probably times when you're
gonna be like I'm so chill that I just
don't really want to do anything today
I'm not gonna lie like there are those
moments but I would say a few things to
that a does it really matter like what
are you striving in the most like like
on a macro level like what are you
striving for exactly is it to ultimately
like chill the [ __ ] out and enjoy things
maybe on some on some plane of existence
secondly just like you said there is a
certain magic in not caring and I think
that when you incorporate some of these
practices which could be as simple as
the morning meditation if you're like
you know what all this like feel-good
stuff don't really care about it you can
get some of the feel-good stuff as a
side affective from just trying to be
more effective by incorporating say
morning journaling with the keeping in
mind the state story strategy
progression and that ever one of the
best pieces of advice I ever received
related to negotiation was super simple
someone said to me he who cares less
wins if you have walkaway power or the
ability to just say no so another based
on that in part I also developed a rule
for myself which I follow I have
followed very very very consistently
which is if so if someone tries to
pressure to meet me to make a decision
quickly the answer's no if you want if
you want a knee-jerk response if
someone's like that's closing tomorrow
or subscribe I don't know like like
either yes or no now like I'm not gonna
leave until you say yes to acts like
then the answer's no absolutely no mmm
and it's like any on-the-spot decision
that you want me to make or forcing me
to make answers now
and there's tremendous power in them and
it's a muscle that you strengthen as you
practice it and you realize like oh [ __ ]
like the world didn't end right and it's
not just it's not that you don't care
like it's more that you're not defined
by the outcome or you're not attached
you don't have an expectation around the
outcome like you know that you're good
outside of however this goes down yeah
yeah yeah and yeah we keep going I mean
there's so many things you can do for
instance and you know I found out
recently that Elon Musk went I think was
in college 30 days on one dollar a day
did he really to teach himself that he
could do it Kevin Kelley one of my I
would consider him a mentor certainly
he's in the book I mean my my vote or
one of my votes for the real world most
interesting man in the world fascinating
guy he's got an Amish beard built his
own house technology futurist who can
predict all sorts of crazy things that
are coming down the line even though he
never once already dropped out of school
his story is just nuts and Kevin also at
periods of time would go on extended
backpacking trips he still does mean
he's gotta be in the 70s now travels
with his kids quite a bit and his wife
and he'll go say a week of sleeping in
his sleeping bag just eating oatmeal and
nothing else
that's it saw my tent yeah right yeah I
sleep in that tab yeah and you do that
every once in a while I try to do
something like that at least a few days
a month I almost always fast at least
three days and months contiguous days a
month which you do need to be careful
with you can [ __ ] yourself up so have
someone qualified supervise you for
stuff like that but when you practice
the the removal of of wants when you
have a renunciation practice of some
type or an ascetic practice of some time
cold exposure also one of my favorites
although it's it's not really the same
category you you begin to teach yourself
not or realize in some cases not only
can you
survive say sleeping in the tent or
going a week just having like shitty
instant coffee and oatmeal and a
sleeping bag but for anyone who's gone
from say the hustle-bustle grind grind
grind to like a seven to ten day hiking
trip how good do you feel after that you
don't just survive you feel so revived
from it's actually like a path towards
that thing that we're all seeking for
we're just doing it by pursuing the
wrong avenues you know that's like
through that simplicity and through that
you know renunciation even if it's just
on a micro level you can find a sense of
self and a sense of calm and and a
contentedness that that you know we're
trying to get and all these other things
that we're doing in our life and that
continue to elude us yeah yeah
absolutely I mean another thing that
I've done for last two or three years
now which I do almost all the time
probably not on book lunch but for for
most of the time screen free Saturdays
so that that doesn't mean there are a
few exceptions I am allowed to use
things like Google Maps or uber or
whatever I need to actually get around
and survive
but no laptop no social media and I have
a lot of things that come out on
Saturday pre-scheduled right so that I
don't have to interact on Saturdays but
so screen free Saturdays have been
really helpful to also train me and to
train other people to realize the world
doesn't end mm-hmm it's amazing that
we're in this place now where it's like
oh my god a whole day on a Saturday when
you don't work that you're not gonna
look at a screen like you know crazy
this is where we're at that's I mean
that's how we've been conditioned
because a fidgety
anxious populace clicking on things is a
economically productive populace for
many of the companies who designed these
things and whose revenue models are
predicated on advertising or contextual
or native advertising you don't even
realize is advertising but that is split
tested so that you have salacious or
scary headlines it's a feel good to be
in Austin and out of that environment
yeah you know Austin feels really good
and I think I think part of it was
finding a better environment for the
next chapters of tim professionally and
personally I've always had a
gravitational pull lost and I wanted to
move there after college just didn't get
the job at trilogy software mmm and then
I got an offer
after elegy is that Jolie mom yeah
College with Joe yeah really yeah no
kidding see what do you went to college
said also Mike maples who's his roommate
I know yeah I knew Joe I just have a
vivid memory of Joe having this house in
Palo Alto that was exactly like those
houses from the social network it's like
and there were just dude like code
monkeys on all these computers and there
would be you know he would throw these
huge parties and all these people there
and I remember when he's like out like
I'm dropping out like I'm my market
window is closing and I was like what
are you talking about this is like 1987
or something yeah I thought he was out
of his mind
yeah yeah he's dead alright and yeah I
don't resent the decision not to hire me
it was but I think I make a terrible
employee
actually so it's likely a good decision
but Austin's always had this pole for me
so I think that it gets really nice as
I'm considering the next things I'm
going to do to have friends who have
nothing to do with tech and that
somebody best friends still live in SF
and I love those people but it's it's
very new for me to be in place like
Austin where one of my best friend's is
a filmmaker another one my best friend's
owns a jujitsu school you know another
friend is a musician
and it goes on and on so the inputs are
so novel and new for me I think that
I'll have a chance to use parts of my
brain that have been maybe neglected for
a while she'll be nice so I'm digging it
I'm really digging that my pop likes
Molly pop likes Austin as well lots of
green well cool man we got a we got to
land this plane
yes excited for you for your new chapter
and it was great getting to know you and
I'm it's gonna be cool I think how this
plays out for you as you continue to
kind of pull on these threads
emotionally so thanks good man I
appreciate you being open and sharing
all that stuff today my pleasure
yeah my pleasure and I would love to
just save her for people listening that
a big part of me opening up in this way
which is getting easier but it's not
easy for me is to hopefully help people
or to minimize how isolated so many
people can feel which I felt for a long
time then I was somehow foul if I ended
up in a dark place or in a dangerous
place even that I was uniquely flawed
and there was no way out and that I was
suffering this alone and that other
people were just fine and I was a broken
toy and what's the point etcetera all
this self-talk again the retreating into
story into these loops that can be
really perilous and certainly punishing
and and can create a lot of suffering
you're not alone and part of the reason
that I asked all the people I interview
in my books the recent ones anyway yeah
about failures and so on is to highlight
the fact that you know most of the
people we think of as superheroes are
walking flaws with tons of insecurities
and neuroses who have somehow figured
out how to build habits around one or
two strengths I mean really and I mean
you and I both know some really really
accomplished people
and they might not talk about it
publicly and they don't have food but
like trust me with rare exception I
can't think of one maybe one but he's
like a robot the rare exception they are
all fighting battles that you know
nothing about and it's safe to assume
also that everyone's fighting about all
you know nothing about there's no
question about it
you know we project an idealized version
of what these people's lives are like
that we that we idolize or or that we
you know sort of see on screens they're
just human beings you know and
successful or not there's no escaping
the human condition yeah there's a
there's there's a there's an expression
in here sometimes in startups or
business which is a don't believe your
own hype it might also be phrased as
don't believe your own press releases
and what I would say just by analogy is
you know if if your Facebook feed or
Instagram feed isn't a complete picture
of your life don't believe that the
story and the hype of all of your
friends seemed the perfect lives on
Instagram Facebook it's still that's
also just the highlight reel and of
course so yeah someone needs to I
remember a friend of mine was saying
very successful friend of mine who's
saying I think where's the Instagram
feed of me like crying eating
haagen-dazs at 2:00 in the morning
watching like reruns and growing pains
like you don't see that very much he's
like someone needs to make that
Instagram account a way out all the
others too but but I think it speaks to
the power of a vulnerability you know
this is this is really what you're doing
like you're you're taking this leap into
you know sharing aspects of who you are
in your story in a public setting which
is frightening and and takes courage but
I think you're experiencing you know the
emotional connection the very real
emotional connection that that creates
with not just your audience but those
people who care for you you know and
it's powerful it's really powerful and
that is that is how you can help other
people heal
that's my hope man so thanks for giving
me a forum to have the discussion and
thanks for bringing it out yeah my
pleasure man
the book is tribe of mentors available
everywhere you buy books they'll be easy
to it's hard to escape Tim on the
internet usually go out of your way
not have them show up somewhere but he
is T Faris on Twitter - ours - ah - s is
correct that's right yeah Tim Ferriss -
our stresses as well on Facebook and
Instagram now - podcasts - podcasts if
you search Tim Ferriss podcasts to have
a bunch pop up if you go in the charts
you should probably see tribe mentors if
just a shorter format the episodes are
10 to 30 minutes instead of one and a
half to three and a half hours which are
my usual in the Tim Ferriss shell and
you can find but also a couple of sample
chapters a full list of mentors from
tribal mentors at tribal mentors calm if
you want to take a peek a lot of good
books out there but I got to give it a
plug you know if you're if you're
looking for a gift book I will say very
self-interested Lee of course that I do
think there's something in this for just
about anybody cuz it's a choose your own
adventure book like you mentioned yeah
truly as I mean you could just pop it
open anywhere randomly or intentionally
and and find good stuff you know it will
you know continue to enrich you
histories ways yes no matter and then
the regardless I certainly wish everyone
very happy very safe holidays and you
know I'll close with one one thought
which is actually borrowed from Gertrude
Stein I read her say this recently now
paraphrase which is the golden rule goes
in two directions and for those of you
who need a reminder do unto others as
you would have them do unto you also do
unto yourself as you would do unto
others so if you're gonna practice
kindness this holiday season which I
hope you do and beyond start with
yourself
you do
[Music]